[Music]
good morning and welcome to technology
day 2009 and welcome to those of you
who've come from a far back to visit MIT
welcome also somewhere out there the web
participants who are participating with
us today via the Internet
I'm Mead Wyman I'm with the class of
1962 I am a member of the class of 62
and I am the chairman of this year's
Technology Day committee the know no
applause is really necessary yet the MIT
Alumni Association ascribes great
importance to the technology day program
and there are there are some reasons I'm
sure there are many reasons for this but
there's one that's particularly
compelling for me we know that when you
come back to MIT for a reunion or a for
a visit or for whatever you many times
would like to have some exposure to the
world-class research and education which
is taking place here Ted the tech day
program is a principal vehicle for
responding to that expectation of course
it's impossible to think about giving
you a comprehensive view of everything
that's happening at MIT that would
simply be impossible and so it falls to
the Technology Day committee to fashion
a program which allows you the audience
to take a look at one of or several of
areas of major major concentration at
the at the Institute today we're going
to address the areas of neuroscience and
artificial intelligence we're very
fortunate to have three outstanding
professors from MIT to give
presentations as a matter of fact I
can't imagine that that it would be
otherwise that we have three outstanding
professors were but we're very delighted
to have professors Sachs Sinha and
Winston these folks will lead us through
the current thinking and work that's
being done in their areas of
specialization and we really appreciate
their willingness to participate with us
today in the proceedings before we start
I have a few administrative matters
which I have to cover with you as a
fellow nerd I am required or I will be
necessary for me to ask you again to
check and make sure that you have turned
all of your electronic devices off
electronic devices which could possibly
distract you could distract the speakers
or your neighbors of course we're
talking principally about cell phones
but and and I should point out that we
do make an exception for hearing aids
and pacemakers
with regard to the question and answer a
question and answer period which follows
each one of the speaker's presentations
we will be asking you to fill out on the
index cards that were given to you at
the outset here your questions write
them out and the ushers toward the end
of the presentations will come down
through the aisles and collect your
questions bring them up to the front
where they'll be organized and then pass
them on up to the to the podium this has
worked very successfully for us it did
work very successfully for us last year
allowing us to process a larger number
of questions than we could when we had
people standing at the microphones I
hope that many of you had a chance to
see the video which was playing before
the start of the program this morning
this is a ten minute video which is a
very interesting portrait of MIT I that
the sound was not not not it wasn't
possible to hear the sound and for those
for that reason and for also for those
of you who may not have seen the video
we want we want to play that at our
30-minute intermission so that you can
see it many of us who've seen that find
that it's a very moving portrait of the
Institute so it will be shown the last
10 minutes of our 30 minute 30 minute
intermission and I could highly
recommend that if you haven't seen that
you come
take a look at it all right we are on a
very tight time schedule today and so I
wanted to mention that my introduction
of our speakers will be quite brief we
can do that in part because there are
very extensive biographical information
there's very good biographical
information and abstracts of the
presentations in your technology day
program so let's get started one of the
very special parts of Technology Day is
the opportunity for us to hear and to
talk with our president Susan Hockfield
Susan Hockfield here's where you'll see
the brief introduction Susan Hockfield
is the 16th president of MIT she's the
first woman and she is the first life
scientist to be a president of our
wonderful institution prior to being a
the Provost at Yale University and and
president and MIT she was and continues
to be a professor in neurobiology I will
I hope that's enough Susan but right
well you you beat me to the punch I
wanted to say welcome thank you so much
okay well good morning everyone it's
great to see you all me thank you for
that kind and brief introduction we're
gonna work on making it even briefer for
next year
I want to also thank me for chairing the
Technology Day committee and all the
members of the committee for putting
together such a spectacular program
today the last time even I saw one
another was when we were joined by
several hundred MIT students at the NCAA
competition where our basketball team
for the first time and it's over 100
year history had made it to the NCAA's
it was an enormous ly exciting event set
of events and one of my favorite stories
the first night I think Mead was there
the first night I could only make it the
second I put the first night the
opposing team we played at that schools
Arena so we had several hundred they had
several hundred students and their
students their fans were taunting ours
by holding up signs that said your
algebra won't help you now
[Laughter]
we won that night
[Applause]
in any case this program this morning is
only part of what has been so far a
spectacular weekend I saw many of you at
the tech night at the Pops on Thursday
night you know I'm beginning to coming
kind of a connoisseur of tech night of
the Pops I think was the best we've ever
had lots of fun great great performance
good program and then yesterday I
declare the commencement was a success
it did not rain until after we finished
awarding over 2,000 degrees exactly
and it's just you know it's an exciting
weekend the mood on campus is very high
and it's just wonderful to have you all
here so thank you for coming to
technology day you are mi t--'s very
best ambassadors and we hope to equip
you for your ambassador Orioles by
providing some of the information as
Mead said it can't be a comprehensive
overview of what we're doing at MIT but
it'll be a little insight into some of
the spectacular work that's going on on
campus and for me as a neuroscientist
it's a little bit like getting three
desserts so I'm very much looking
forward to these marvelous presentations
today and now before we go any further
with the formal part of today's program
I want to capitalize on this moment of
having so many alumni here in the
audience to introduce to enormous ly
important people one eye we all need to
thank and the other we're gonna welcome
so I would invite Sherwin Greenblatt and
Judy Cole to join me up here come on up
don't be shy sure when is you know and
Judy also these are not people who are
used to being the limelight so I'm gonna
as they're coming up on to talk about
first sherwin this past year has been a
year of many transitions for the Alumni
Association they move from oh seven
different locations in three different
buildings into one spectacular facility
at 600 Memorial Drive and I hope many of
you have had a chance to see that this
weekend this year has been a time of
searching for a new leader for the
Alumni Association and through all of
these transitions the Alumni Association
has been more than Abele led by Sherwin
greenblatt Sherwin in my mind is kind of
the canonical
my T alumnus he's of course he graduated
from MIT he has had he had a great
career he started as employee number one
at the Bose Corporation and then a
couple of years ago after a whole career
opposed he retired as president of the
Bose Corporation and I would say he
retired but really he tried to retire
because his retirement activity was
running the venture mentoring service
for MIT which you know many of us
wouldn't consider that to be retirement
so he's demonstrating what I found to be
an almost universal characteristic among
MIT alumni the distinct failure at being
able to retire if any any of you need
need advice sherwin is an expert so when
I first started in the summer of my my
first year at MIT we needed an interim
executive vice president for the
Institute and I called on Sherwin to
take on that role and when the three
months that I had recruited him to serve
turned into more than a year he
continued to serve a Blee and then when
our new executive vice president and
treasurer terry stone was found and she
started sure when went back to retiring
at the VMS but then when we needed an
interim leader as the EVP of the Alumni
Association of course I turned to sure
when again but as the months went on he
became increasingly anxious to leave
because he's ready to go on to a new job
another new job which as a grandfather
so last week he's celebrated the birth
of Brice Jennings Greenblatt his first
grandchild and so I have some gifts to
thank Sherwin for his service and to get
him on his way into his next job please
join me in thanking him
[Applause]
now we wouldn't have let Sherwin leave I
wouldn't have let Sherwin lead unless we
knew that the Alumni Association would
be in terrific hands and so it is a very
great pleasure to introduce to you for
those of you who have not already met
her
Judy Cole our new EBP and CEO of the
Alumni Association now I won't take the
time to formally introduce her I hope
that you all have read her background
and I do hope that many of you will find
an opportunity to meet Judy this weekend
she could not be better prepared for us
everyone who interviewed Judy knew at
once that she would get it about MIT
there's a kind of intensity and humor a
devotion and ability to work really hard
and believe me and I hope all of you can
believe me now
Judy is just a terrific new leader for
the Alumni Association so please welcome
Judy Cole to MIT into the AAA
[Applause]
okay now my task is to give a
comprehensive tour of what's been going
on in MIT this year we'd described how
we don't have to be comprehensive in
technology day but I mean I feel I've
got to touch a lot of things so it's
going to be a whirlwind tour I apologize
the punchline of the race across the
campus this morning is that it has been
as you all know a very demanding year
but we have had a great year here at the
Institute I want to be sure that I leave
some time to hear your questions so let
me just kind of lay out the three things
I want to talk about the first is mi
t--'s role serving in these difficult
times the second is I'll give you an
update on how we're coping with the
financial downturn including where we
are on our campaign for students and
then I will describe one important
critical source of our momentum for the
future so while the pattern of
activities at the end of the year has a
kind of timeless nature to it that
timelessness and the sameness of the
events the wonderful repetition of the
events has thrown up against the really
extraordinary difference that we face
this year just one measure of where we
are this year compared to last year on
June 6 last year the Dow was at 12200 on
Friday was at eight thousand seven sixty
and as I said I'm going to talk about
the impact of that downturn on MIT in
just a little while but despite the
rigors of dealing with that we have been
on an enormous ly productive track the
new administration in Washington has
very articulated articulately stated
that it values science analysis research
these are the things that MIT values on
inauguration day our lecture halls world
were filled with people watching the
inauguration remotely and at the point
when President Obama said that it was
time to restore science to its rightful
place everyone left to their feet and
applauded and my guess is there are not
too many places in America who received
those words the way they received here
at MIT what I often say about this
administration in my great hope is it
will be cool to be smart what a relief
and
[Applause]
and the hope in this is that the values
that MIT holds so dearly will become
more mainstream as our nation grasps the
importance of science and technology
innovation entrepreneurship for our
future more substantively
on April 27th President Obama gave a
speech at the National Academies and he
made a very strong declaration of his
support for science and I'm just going
to read one passage from what is a truly
amazing speech and I would recommend it
to all of you he said at such a
difficult moment there are those who say
we cannot afford to invest in science
that support for research is somehow a
luxury at a moment defined by
necessities I fundamentally disagree
science is more essential for our
prosperity our security our health our
environment and our quality of life than
it has ever been
we believe this here and perhaps most
important president obama embraces a
knowledge-based innovation economy this
is the principle of growth economics
that was laid out so cogently by
professor robert solow
a nobel prize winner here in our
economics department restoring the
economy of the country will demand the
same kind of fuel that powered the
information technology and biotechnology
revolutions and the basic concept is you
invest at the federal level as
generously as you can in research that
research turns into innovations those
innovations are taking it you know off
campuses out of research labs to start
new companies and out of those companies
coming turley new industries this is a
perfect assignment for MIT we have many
opportunities to serve in Washington
right now and we're doing so in a number
of ways
members of our faculty have been
seconded from our campus down to
Washington to have leadership roles in
the OMB the Council of Economic Advisors
at the Department of Defense as I said
many of our faculty but also many of our
alumni are serving in government roles
there are a large number of people from
the ph.d program in our Department of X
serving in the administration to members
of PCAST the President's Council of
Advisors on science and technology our
MIT faculty and I participated with
President Obama in a briefing on green
technology opportunities in mid-march
following that we hosted on campus
congressman Ed Markey Carol Browner
and the science advisor John Holdren for
a session on the energy legislation that
has been moving through the house and in
mid-april we hosted sorry the beginning
of this month we hosted secretary of may
we in May we hosted Secretary of Energy
Steven Chu who gave a Karl Taylor
Compton lecture here now both the
secretary Chu's lecture and the session
with Marquis Holdren and Brown are
available on a mighty world if any of
you wants to watch that as is my event
with President Obama at the White House
now MIT is primed to serve in other ways
not just in Washington but here on
campus and I will briefly review where
we are on two of our large initiatives
one on energy and the other at this
wonderfully interesting interphase where
life sciences is joining the physical
sciences and engineering for this
audience on I don't need to describe the
four urgent reasons why we need to be
very serious about tackling the energy
challenge in terms of energy demand we
are on track to double energy use
worldwide by 2050 and perhaps earlier
energy security is a pressing problem we
depend on undependable countries for a
lot of our energy supplying in part as
far as the climate there is general
agreement that we are contributing to
the global warming and there is recent
data from MIT professor Ron Prince work
and the MIT joint program on science and
policy of global change that's showing a
marked acceleration beyond what had been
predicted in terms of global warming by
the way you can get to Ron Prinn or the
joint programs website very easily and
see the data that they've been studying
and now of course we have the added
incentive shall we say of economic
downturn and I believe that fundamental
economic growth is really the only path
to getting our nation out of the
economic difficulties were in right now
mi t--'s energy initiative we call it
mighty was officially launched two and a
half years ago the first phase of this
we relied on mostly on industry
partnerships and we raised over two
hundred million dollars to fund research
and education in in energy the energy
initiative from it's very beginning is
has been radically cross-disciplinary
this means it reaches across all of our
five schools maybe not every department
but how close to every department is
participating in some way at this point
Ernie Moniz the director and Bob
Armstrong the deputy director of the
Energy Initiative estimate that about
20% of our faculty are participating in
the energy initiative our students are
as you might anticipate wildly excited
about this
there is a mostly graduate student led
energy Club one of several student
energy organizations the student-led
energy club the last time I talked about
it I was told it had 1500 members but
that data was a week old and some
students shouted from the audience no
it's 1700 it's a lot there are a lot of
members most are students and these are
graduate students who intend to be
energy professionals it's an inspiring
group so the energy initiative takes us
from policy and economics to concepts
for new buildings and cityscapes to of
course basic science and new
technologies we have roles to lead both
in policy and in research but also in
education for those of you who are
interested in some of our policy pieces
if you get to the mighty website you can
get a link to the policy pieces we've
already done on the future of coal the
future of nuclear the future of
geothermal there's a new report
evaluating the cap-and-trade system in
the EU and we've got a couple of new
reports underway one on the nuclear fuel
cycle which will be absolutely critical
understanding what we're going to do
with nuclear waste if nuclear is going
to be part of the energy solution going
forward
another study on natural gas and one on
solar and those new studies will be
coming out in the next year or so
on the research frontier there are no
silver bullets we do not believe that
there is a single technology that is
going to get the world from our current
mix of use to a mix of use that will
actually sustain the new demand and will
reduce the amount of co2 we push into
the atmosphere so we are pursuing a
portfolio of technologies we divide them
into the transitional and the
transformational there are technologies
that we use today that simply have to be
improved and they can be improved in the
short term we're working very hard on
those kinds of technologies and the
transformational are all those marvelous
alternative technologies that we dream
about using but we're not ready yet
to use them at scale now while I say
there are a lot of different
technologies under development over
these last couple of years the focus of
the energy initiative has really come to
rest on solar and solar both in terms of
materials for conversion and of course
the wonderfully exciting area here at
MIT is the development of new storage
technologies there are over a dozen new
battery technologies under development
now at MIT now people say well why solar
I mean besides that it's such a great
challenge
you know I say well you know Willie
Sutton robbed banks because that's where
the money was and solar that's where the
energy is and one of our faculty who
does work on solar said well you know we
should be using all that energy for
doing something more than just heating
asphalt I think we can figure that one
out
I mentioned the huge certain interest in
the education domain the energy
initiative has a task force on education
that brought forward this year and a
very exciting new minor in energy most
of our majors and minors at MIT exist in
departments or in particular programs
the energy miner the governance of which
was approved by the faculty at our May
meeting stretches across again all five
of our schools and reaches into many
many departments and will provide our
future energy professionals with a kind
of education that will support them
the economics of energy to the science
of energy to the design of energy and
they will be able to really lead we
believe as they leave MIT that minor
will be rolled out this fall as I
mentioned the first stage of the energy
initiative was largely powered through
industry partnerships because we didn't
have confidence at the time that we
could secure the kind of funding that we
would need from the federal government
so we had wonderful industry support I
mentioned over 200 million dollars the
Department of Energy has changed its
direction happily and we are doing a
very good job at securing the new
funding that's coming from the
Department of Energy we have also been
the you know enormous ly grateful
recipients of some important
philanthropic gifts and the reason why
private philanthropy is so important for
the energy initiative is their their
their areas that industry and frankly
the federal government just are not
interested in supporting we don't get a
lot of support for education so the
energy miner is going to really rely on
private philanthropy and the other place
where it's hard to get support from
either industry or the government is
support for new professorships we have
believe it or not some gaps and where
our professors cover and so we would
like to have five more five new
professorships in energy two of which
have been generously funded by alumni so
that's a very quick tour of the Energy
Initiative
let me turn next to this exciting area
where the life sciences is coming into
conversation with the physical sciences
and engineering and it's happening all
over campus about a third of our faculty
in the School of Engineering are either
using the tools of life sciences or
collaborating with the life sciences in
some way and it is not all about
biomedicine one of the most exciting
battery projects that we have going on
is a project that Angie Belcher is
leading from the Department of material
sciences and engineering and the
department biological engineering that
has discovered a way to make viruses
incorporate battery materials and then
self-assemble into the anode and cathode
for batteries just one example of tools
of the life sciences being used outside
of biomedicine one place that is very
much in the biomedical domain where this
convergence with life sciences
and engineering and the physical
sciences happening in our new cancer
activity those of you who have walked
along Vassar and manes see another big
building going up that is the Koch
Institute for Integrative Cancer
Research it's a very exciting part of
campus if you look at the buildings that
you know sit around and what goes on
inside them this is really where the
Life Sciences and engineering are coming
into a conversation it's between the Ray
Emery estate a Center where the
Department of Electrical Engineering
computer science sits and the department
of biology in the Koch biology building
it is in the center of what I call the
Great Circle this new building is a very
interesting advance on what MIT has done
in cancer people often don't know that
MIT has worked in cancer but our Center
for cancer research was established in
1974 the leader then was Salvador Luria
a phenomenal biologist who had already
won the Nobel Prize laureate with the
Department of Biology recruited 12
biologists into the center for cancer
research of those 12 biologists for have
won the Nobel Prize so far in addition
to great you know science appreciated by
the Nobel Prize Committee the
fundamental discoveries underlying the
new targeted cancer drugs came out of
MIT Center for cancer research but when
I spoke with Tyler Jack's the director
of the Center for cancer researcher what
was the center for cancer research about
where the future for center of research
at MIT was moving he described an
incredible exciting activity that was
going on where the life scientists and
engineers were beginning to talk to one
another in incredibly productive ways so
it will not surprise you that the Koch
Institute for Integrative Cancer
Research which now puts the Center for
cancer research in our history will be
populated by about a dozen cancer
biologists and a dozen engineers who are
interested in helping us figure out how
to diagnose treat and prevent cancer in
new ways
it's very very exciting it's exciting
for the faculty the students have
enormous interest
and we believe that this is an approach
that really is almost uniquely MIT and
we have a unique way to approach it
people have asked me you know why do we
think there's this combination of
biology and engineering can really help
in our fight against cancer and one of
my responses of course is well we're
already doing it and making huge
advances but another is that it's been
done in other fields if we look at heart
disease and stroke over the last 25 30
years in the United States we've
decreased death from heart disease and
stroke by 63 percent an astonishing
product of investments mostly out of the
National Institutes of Health and if we
look at what were the critical
discoveries and the critical advances
it's both biology and engineering it's
been both drugs and devices the biology
was understanding the metabolism of
cholesterol and developing drugs to make
cholesterol metabolism work better and
those who didn't so the statins and it's
also devices drug eluting stents these
devices that prop open clogged vessels
so we believe that the same kind of
approach in cancer will result in the
same kind of wonderful advances the
building as I said is rising fast this
afternoon there is going to be an event
for a wonderful plan to raise some money
to help us support that building and we
do need a lot more support to get that
building up and get it get it working
well part of that building will be the
Swanson class of 1960 biotechnology
Center we're going to be celebrating
that and invent this afternoon I invite
you to join us it's going to be at the
Broad Institute at 3:30 and what this
biotech the Swanson biotechnology Center
will be is a celebration of the life of
Bob Swanson as I said an MIT alumnus the
founder of Genentech and truly a 20th
century legend as I said if you'd like
to join us please do let me now turn to
the question that really is on
everyone's mind although there are other
things that are so fascinating and it's
this question of the economic downturn
in our
finances of course it affects MIT in
December I was describing a situation
where all of our revenue streams would
be compromised now I say that most of
our revenue streams will be compromised
compromised certainly we are
anticipating decreased revenues from our
endowment for up tuition and from gifts
but one of our revenue streams clearly
has not and doesn't look like they do be
compromised at least in the near term
and that's research the Provost Rafael
rife and I and Terry stone the EVP and
treasurer have been focused very much on
our research volume which was frankly
declining for many years this year for
the first time and I think about five
years we have an increase in research
volume by about 6% very good news and
that's before the kinds of programs that
are coming out of the ARRA or the
stimulus bill or the really great new
budgets that the administration has put
forward for the science agencies let me
talk a little bit about our endowment
all large institutional endowments have
lost value we have been planning for an
adamant decline on the order of 30% last
year July 1st our endowment student
about 10 billion dollars so we have been
operating toward an endowment that would
be 7 billion fact is we got a report
from our chief investment officer Seth
Alexander this week and he says right
now we're tracking about 20 percent
maybe 25 percent down that's very good
news because a couple months ago it
really was 30 percent and we don't know
we're going to finish there we're going
to continue with a planning assumption
of the endowment value loss of about 30
percent this means in practical terms
that we have to take a hundred and fifty
million dollars out of a 1 billion
dollar general Institute budget and our
plan is to do that in two or three years
we are going to take 5% out we have
taken 5% actually almost 6% out for the
year going forward and we have a number
of activities going on to get the next
10 percent out including something
called the idea bank many of you may
have actually contributed to the idea
Bank this is a web tool where people can
enter their ideas for how we might do
things better more efficiently more
economically and you can then vote on
ideas it's been a very interesting
online conversation we also have put
together have charged a task force for
budget planning the task force has
almost 200 people on it they come from
across the Institute faculty staff and
students and the task force has nine
working groups each of which is focused
on a particular area of our activities
and they really do span everything we do
across campus the initial report from
that group will come out at the end of
this month the final report in October
so that we can implement some of those
or hopefully many of the ideas that are
coming out of the task force for the
budget for FY 11 let me talk about
tuition a little bit our financial the
financial need of our students obviously
is increasing last year and kind of mid
you know between semesters about 20
students came forward because their fact
their families had suffered a decline in
their financial situation this year
about 40 students did we're planning to
increase our financial aid budget for
next year by about 10% to make it just
over 80 million dollars so we expect
that we will be increasing our
expenditures and financial aid even
while the funding that supports it has
been declining in the realm of gifts
obviously we rely so so deeply on
private philanthropy gifts fund any
number of things that we do that we just
can't fund any other way and I would say
the good news is it's not as bad as we
expected this year so thank you all of
you you have been generous in ways that
I would say I could not have anticipated
last November in December it has really
been an extraordinary year we measure
our philanthropic progress in two ways
we look at cash that's come in and then
we also look at pledges for new gifts
pledges for future commitments in terms
of cash we're down about only about five
percent from last year so this is very
good
most people are fulfilling on the
commitments they've made in the past but
as I look forward I'm a little bit more
nervous about looking forward because
our new gifts it
and new pledges for those gifts are down
on the order of about 25 percent from
last year now I say that but you have to
remember last year we had an
extraordinary year but if weak so if we
compare where we are with gifts and
pledges to a three-year average we are
down on the order of you know eight or
ten percent so we're doing fine but we
have to really think incorporating to
our budget planning and anticipated less
powerful stream out of gifts and we have
in the past they have been there have
been stories of just extraordinary
generosity this year that are enormous
ly heartwarming and enormous ly
encouraging one of our alumni who is
enormous ly generous for his capacity
every year he gives us a thousand
dollars and it is we have considered
this at the limit of his capacity actual
a little bit beyond it wrote a lovely
letter to us in December saying that the
economic downturn caused him to really
think about what was most important to
him what really mattered in the world
and so this year he sent us $2,000
amazing
[Applause]
and one thing that has come you know
through many of these stories this year
is that while a lot of markets have lost
in value the market for meaning has
really increased in value this year and
MIT I think really does deliver on real
value I talked about our response to the
budget reductions I have to tell you and
you will all know this this is not easy
we're putting I think a very important
positive face on it we think it's an
opportunity to do things that we
couldn't do before we just didn't have
reason enough to do before but it just
is simply it's an unhappy you know
process any decision we make will not be
greeted unanimously with you know
approval and I think the community has
done a wonderful job of just being quite
practical and quite hard-headed about
the things we need to do we want to come
out of this with an institute that is
leaner and stronger that is more
strategic we have to preserve our core
strengths and values it's an opportunity
for us to actually think about what
those are I will call out just two of
them one is financial aid we are
committed to retaining our policy of
need-blind admission and need-based aid
and meeting the full need of our
admitted students we have to do that
because the you know one huge source of
strength MIT are the remarkable students
we bring to the campus we also are going
to continue to hire faculty because it
is important to refresh our faculty by
bringing young people into the Institute
and that's something we're going to
continue to do as long as we possibly
can
how do we sustain this kind of activity
obviously I've been talking about your
generosity but private landfill Anthropy
has been a huge part of it we launched
our campaign for students last October
just as the market was starting to tank
they tell me every time MIT launches a
campaign that's what happens we should
stop doing that
um the campaign for students was
designed as a birthday present for our
one hundred and fiftieth birthday in
2011 we're actually doing quite well on
it we've raised about 65% of our target
which is five hundred million dollars
and I know that many of you who have
been generous and contributing to the
campaign and I really can't thank you
enough that campaigns target is students
we're raising money for undergraduate
financial aid for graduate fellowships
for money to enhance our educational
environment and also for the living
environment for students we've got a lot
of work to do on all four of those areas
and the campaign for students will
accelerate it so let me just close with
a description of one huge source of our
momentum and that is our spectacular
students we have now admitted our class
of 2013 you know the numbers scare
anyone of us who got into college years
and years ago applications this year
went up 17% to a record high good news
in terms of the world seeing MIT as a
place that's going to pass pave a path
to the future but what that means of
course is that our admission rate was
very low we admitted ten point six
percent of the students who applied
yield sixty five percent of the students
we offered admission to have decided to
come to MIT and this is quite amazing
considering the environment a number of
our competitors schools have stopped
using any kind of early admission
program which you know means students
are applying to more and more schools
and so the face off when they've been
accepted at a lot of schools to decide
for MIT and not another school is very
very much tougher and also as you all
know there are some very generous very
aggressive financial aid policies and
some of our schools which frankly we
just can't we can't match for for some
of our students any way you describe
this class it takes your breath away 90%
of them graduated in the top 5% of their
classes 20% are academic all-stars
meaning that they've won some national
and
national competition 20% are stars in
music the arts or athletics but my
favorite statistic always is this one
19% of next year's freshman class are
their first are the first in their
families to go to college
now this year's class as you know is the
first class that I admitted as freshmen
so I know a whole lot of them and as
they came up to shake my hands yesterday
it was all I could do to you know keep
them just saying can you please you're
so wonderful can you stay but no the
world needs you go ahead but they are
remarkable students and I can tell you
I've met a lot of those 19 percent who
are the first in their families to go to
college and these are remarkable people
and I often say and many of you have
heard me say this that MIT is a place
where the MIT where the American dream
comes true
and they come to MIT MIT changes their
lives and then they go out and change
the world this year's graduating class
you know showed me that again and again
this year's student awards are
breathtaking we you know in terms of the
the elite national awards we have had a
year like none other in the past two of
our students won Rhodes scholarships for
one Marshalls 13:1 Fulbright's we've
never had a year like this it just you
know shows you that the world
appreciates the kind of student that
comes out of MIT for marshals let me
just give you a sense that that's ten
percent of the Marshall scholarships
awarded this year came to MIT students
these students just you know heighten
our sense of mission and responsibility
and stewardship and to serve them and
those to come we have to maintain an
unwavering focus on producing the
innovations and the innovators even in
or I would say especially in difficult
times like these today
in pursuing that mission we depend
absolutely on the loyalty the enthusiasm
the generosity of our alumni you are
indeed our information army you carry
the spirit the values and the good of
MIT into the world and I can't thank you
enough for that let me stop now and take
some questions thanks for coming to
technology day
[Applause]
yeah whatever you say need short okay
one answer one-word answers yes and yes
and no questions yes sure the first
question is strategically as we look
ahead will MIT continue to concentrate
in these two areas of yeah so these two
ideas are very big ideas and I think
these two ideas will continue for my
guess is a decade or more but even while
these are two of the major initiatives
that were at reach across campus there
are probably hundreds of fantastically
interesting and important projects going
on and so we shouldn't you know think
that these are the only things that MIT
is doing or you know that they will be
you know the only initiatives going
forward you will hear about some
exciting stuff that's going on in the
brain sciences and intelligence world
and you know everywhere around us there
are brilliant new new activities
cropping up thank you I'm gonna try to
do this one because I think it's it's at
least controversial there was a lot of
interest in in the energy information
that you provided here's a question
which is if we're convinced about global
warming and are considering a major
alteration in the economy and the
production of gas greenhouse gases
through cap-and-trade why does an MIT
advocate for a serious study of a
contrarian view to see if there are
other ways that we might improve improve
the output or
the output of greenhouse gases so this
is a bit controversial and I don't mind
talking about it but I always press this
by saying I am NOT the expert so I rely
on the experts at MIT for those of you
who are deeply interested in the science
behind this I recommend the website for
the joint programme on climate change it
has lots of data lots of analysis by
very very interesting and thoughtful
scientists in terms of other approaches
the other thing I'd recommend in terms
of what we you know what kind of
economic and policy approach should be
taken
dennee Ellerman did a study and I
mentioned this on the EU cap-and-trade
which is very interesting obviously the
purpose of the study was do you
determine whether it can be effective
whether that's the direction we should
apply at MIT so we you know the energy
the mighty and the website has a huge
amount of data on it and we are
interested in pursuing any number of
alternatives because we we don't know
that we have have a single right answer
yet okay fine thank you the last
question then would be it seems that the
transformational approaches to
alternative energy are on a very long
time frame for development what can be
done to accelerate that yeah so what can
be done to accelerate it is to fund the
research they are on it a long time
frame anyone you know everyone dreams
about you know a all solar to
all-electric energy equation we're a
long way away from that we're a long way
away from it because the conversion
technologies are too expensive and
insufficiently developed storage
technologies or not you know ready for
primetime yet either one of the things
that I find sobering is the national
investment in energy research the budget
for basic rnd annually that the
government is 4.5 billion dollars it's a
lot of money you can say but the kinds
of really world-changing innovations
that have come out of the Health
Sciences come out of an NIH budget that
now is about thirty billion dollars a
year so our investments have been small
and they've been episodic so we've been
on a roller coaster of federal
investments in energy research and you
just can't make progress
that way so we have to commit to a
sustained high level of funding of R&D
the companies aren't going to do it the
federal government has to do that but on
the industry side we also have a
fascinating anomaly that if you look at
the investments of let's just say
pharmaceutical companies in R&D they
spend somewhere between fifteen and
twenty percent of revenues on R&D and a
lot of innovation comes out of those
investments if you look at the energy
sector on the other hand energy
companies American based energy
companies invest one quarter of one
percent of their revenues in R&D so we
have here on the one hand you know if
you look at what has happened in
biomedicine over the last thirty years
it is miraculous but to get those kinds
of miraculous changes you need to invest
federal-aid love about 30 billion a year
and the the companies also need to be
investing and the energy domain we just
haven't had the kind of focused
sustained investments either in the
private sector or in the government to
really change the game so I didn't
follow the money I mean money we really
as a nation have to commit to doing -
changing this I'll tell you one other
sobering insight into our country's
interest in changing the energy equation
of the 14 or so companies that have
signed up to be our industry partners
that are funding the kinds of research
that I think we need to make solar
viable to come up with new kinds of
storage devices new kinds of batteries
only two of those companies are American
based and it's not that we haven't been
approaching the American based energy
companies as aggressively as we've been
approaching the non American companies
so just as a nation we really haven't
focused on this in a way that would
create the kind of transformation that I
believe we need we need it for the
economics as well as you can just say
climate change to change the sign there
are plenty of reasons that we need to
change the energy equation I'm afraid we
have to stop it's such a pleasure to
have you spend time with us and and I
wish we could spend more time but I'm
afraid we have to thank you thank you
very much for coming
our next speaker is Professor Rebecca
Saxe
Rebecca is an assistant professor of
cognitive neuroscience at MIT her main
area of research is in the theory of the
mind and this morning professor sacks
will take us into how the brain creates
the mind Rebecca welcome
[Applause]
okay thanks so much Thank You Susan so
that amazing introduction to MIT thanks
me and thanks everybody for coming to
listen to me so I'm quite a different
note today I'm gonna talk to you about
the problem of other minds and the
problem I want to talk to you about it's
slightly different from the standard
problem of other minds you might have
heard about as an undergrad at MIT the
old problem of other Minds the one that
puzzled philosophers used to be do other
people have Minds how can we know
whether other people have Minds because
it's possible that maybe you have a mind
but everybody else in this room is just
a really convincing robot designed by
the MIT Media Lab and I think after
Patrick Winston's talk today that might
not seem so implausible but for the
moment I'm gonna assume that the answer
to this question is yes other people
have Minds many people have Minds many
of them are in this room and so we're
not going to talk about that today a
second problem of other Minds one that
puzzles novelists and parents and
teachers and spouses is why is it so
hard to know other minds or actually why
is it so hard to change other minds
right why is it so hard to figure out
what people want and what they think and
to change what they wanted to change
what they think and I think this problem
is often put most eloquently and
specifically by novelists so for example
in one of my favorite statements Philip
Roth in American pastoral wrote and yet
what are we to do about this terribly
significant business of other people so
ill-equipped are we all to envision one
another's interior workings and
invisible aims I think that's a really
eloquent statement of this problem we
all face and as a teacher and as a
spouse I think this is an incredibly
important problem but as a scientist
it's actually a different problem that
I'm interested in which is why is it so
easy to know other minds so in
particular I want to pose to this
problem I want to convince you that it's
a puzzle why it's so easy and that it's
a puzzle that we're beginning to start
working on so in particular it's so easy
for all of us as human adults
to see and to recognize and to think
about other minds in a number of ways
that are quite remarkable so one way is
from very little information that you
might get from a scene or a moment you
can make really accurate and powerful
inferences about what somebody's
thinking so you can guess what this
woman is thinking from just a momentary
exposure to one image of her or what
this man might be thinking and you might
say well that's because you recognize
those images you've seen things like
that before you've been in those places
and so an important insight from social
psychologists that's not true we can
take all of that away and give you just
a little bit of movement of a sick this
is six seconds of geometric shapes
moving and from this you can see
relationships between the two characters
you can see the concern of the triangle
the nervousness about jumping the
decision to jump the genius of flipping
the trapdoor before the evil circle
comes in all of that out of six seconds
of the movements of two geometric shapes
so that's one sense in which it's
amazingly easy we get lots and lots of
information from apparently very little
in the stimulus but another way to be
amazed at how easy it is to think about
other minds is to think about what it is
that our brains are having to do so we
as human adults can figure out a problem
like this Julia doesn't want to marry
Paris and she asks the friar who tells
her she can pretend to be dead in a fire
sends a message to Romeo who doesn't get
it so he goes when he gets the other
message he thinks Juliet is dead so when
he sees Juliet he decides to kill
himself we can follow that kind of crazy
complicated logical stream cut which is
kind of amazing
or I can say a sentence to you which has
one mental state embedded inside another
inside another like I hope I'll convince
you to believe that the brain does what
I think it does
that's for mental states one inside
another and as a neuroscientist what I
try to figure out is well how does the
meat inside your head make sense of the
sentence I just said so in particular we
know a little bit about the structure of
the brain we know that it's a group of
cells called neurons connected to one
another and they can send really simple
messages from one to another so a neuron
fires that is it
basically an electrical spike down to
the next cells which it's connected
every neuron is sending many many many
messages out everyone is receiving many
many many from the neurons to which it's
connected and the pattern over space and
time of this those spikes come in
determine whether the next cell sends a
message on or not so we have a huge
network of cells sending these
incredibly simple messages and this is
the huge explanatory gap of neuroscience
is how do we get from these simple
messages being passed from one cell to
another an enormous network to
constructing the meaning of this
sentence with four mental states
embedded inside one another and the
honest answer is we have no idea so so
neuroscience the project of human
cognitive neuroscientists to try to
bridge that gap to try to go from the
way neurons function which is pretty
similar between humans and monkeys and
mice and actually sea slugs with pretty
similar function of neurons to the
really unique capacities of the human
brain in terms of the cognition and the
mind and so that's the project of human
cognitive neuroscience which is using
amazing modern technologies that let us
study human brains directly by taking
pictures of them without cutting holes
in anybody's head and so that's my
research and what I'm going to talk to
you about today is the research I've
been doing one particular area which is
looking at this kind of thinking that we
do with our minds thinking about other
people's thoughts and the first thing I
want to tell you about that is that
although it's easy for us now to solve
to think about Romeo and Juliet
it doesn't start easy in fact we can
watch children slowly and effortfully
building up an idea of how other minds
work and watching that developmental
history and childhood can give us clues
about what to look for in their brains
and so to show you about that I'm gonna
introduce you to a task that we do with
children this is called the false belief
task and in this task this child is
going to be asked to think about and
make predictions about what somebody
else will do given their thoughts and in
particular this is a five year old
is gonna be asked to do this and what
I'm gonna show you after that is a three
year old I'm gonna show you a well-known
transition between three and five so
we're gonna start with a five year old
who's pretty much got it his name is
Ivan and you a Pirates really like what
Pirates really like cheese sandwiches I
love yeah so Ivan has his cheese
sandwich and he says
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum I really love cheese
sandwiches when Ivan puts his sandwich
over here on top of the pirate chest and
Ivan says you know what I need a drink
with my lunch and so Ivan goes to get a
drink and while eivin is away the wind
comes and it blows the sandwich down
onto the grass and now here comes the
other pirate this pirate is called
Joshua and Joshua also really loves
cheese sandwich so Joshua has a cheese
sandwich and he says yum yum yum yum yum
I love cheese sandwiches and he puts his
cheese sandwich over here on top of the
pirate chest that was Joshua's that's
right yeah that's exactly right now oh
so now Joshua goes off to get a drink
Ivan comes back and he says I want my
cheese sandwich so which one do you
think Ivan's gonna take you think he's
gonna take that one all right let's see
oh yeah you were right he took that one
so now Ivan has this cheese sandwich and
now Joshua comes and Joshua says I'm
really mad at you Ivan why is Joshua mad
at Ivan yeah he took his sandwich that's
right exactly right okay so that's a
five-year-old all over the problem of
somebody else having a false belief but
if we look just by a year and a half
earlier this is a three and a half year
old who's heard the same story he's
gonna give quite a different answer
and now Ivan's coming back and Ivan says
I want my cheese sandwich which sandwich
is he gonna take
do you think he's gonna take that one
let's see what happens let's see what he
does here comes Ivan he says I want my
cheese sandwich and he takes this one oh
why did he take that one so this
three-year-old first of all predicts but
that the pirate will take the sandwich
that's really his I'll take the one on
the grass that's really his he won't not
that'll take the one where he left his
and then faced with contradictory
evidence even when he sees the pirate
taking the wrong sandwich the
three-year-old doesn't think of the
possibility that it's a mistake or that
he has a false belief the three-year-old
instead comes up with some other reason
why he might want to take the other
sandwich in this case he might want to
take the other sandwich because his was
on the grass so developmental
psychologists for the last thirty years
since this pattern was first observed in
the 1980s have been studying this
transition trying to understand what's
the difference between the mind and
brain of a three year old and a five
year old such that the five year old is
all over what somebody else might be
thinking and what that will cause them
to do whereas the three year old seems
to be missing this huge aspect of other
minds namely the possibility that they
might have a false belief now what will
probably come as no surprise to parents
in the room but took developmental
psychologists a lot longer to get to is
that five-year-olds are not done
developing their ability to understand
other minds they still got lots to learn
and in particular what we've recently
started doing is asking children a
slightly different question and when we
do this we see credit a different and
much later developmental trajectory so
in this case we're going to ask children
not just what somebody will do but to
make a moral judgment about their action
so I'll show you first what the
three-year-old says here comes Joshua
and Joshua says I'm really mad at you
Ivan why is Joshua really mad at Ivan
yeah that was I haven't being mean and
naughty for taking Joshua's sandwich
yeah should I even get in trouble for
taking Joshua's sandwich yeah all right
so it's maybe not surprising that the
three-year-old thinks I even should get
in trouble because he doesn't understand
that I even took the sandwich because he
thought it was his but now he is the
five-year-old
this five-year-old was all over
understanding that Ivan thought that the
sandwich he was taking was his but look
what happens when I asked him a question
Josh was really mad and he's crying did
Ivan was Ivan being mean and naughty for
taking Joshua's sandwich yeah and it's
not until 7:00 that children start
giving the answer that grown-ups would
get that's right he's taking the one on
the box but uh-oh here comes Joshua and
Joshua says I'm really mad at you Ivan
why is Joshua really mad at Ivan so can
I ask you something
should I even get in trouble for taking
Joshua's sandwich no did is Ivan being
mean for taking Joshua's sandwich
no oh my favorite version of this was
one when I asked him when his mother was
in the room should I even get in trouble
and he looked straight at his mother and
said no so we can see here is two pieces
of a really complicated developmental
story where children are learning more
and more how to think about other
people's minds and use that to make
decisions so between 3 & 5 the children
are learning how to predict what
somebody will do given their false
beliefs and it's not until 7 that they
start to integrate those ideas into more
complicated judgments like moral
judgments so those patterns and the
development gives us a hint of what to
look for and when we now go back to the
human brain and ask well what brain
regions are the children and even we as
adults using when we're trying to solve
these kinds of problems so to study this
we put human adults into an fMRI scanner
and we ask them to solve the equivalent
kind of problem but now made a little
bit more appropriate for grown-ups
so here's an example somebody would be
lying in the scanner and they're reading
a little story like this John told Emily
that his car was a Porsche actually just
John's car was a Ford but Emily doesn't
know anything about cars
and then we asked true or false Emily
thinks John's car is a Porsche so this
is more or less pirates and cheese
sandwiches for grown-ups and then we can
look at well what regions of their brain
are showing more metabolism more
activity while the grown-ups are reading
these stories compared to very similar
logical problem-solving that doesn't
require them to think about anybody's
thoughts um so these are the results
from what we call typical human adults
they're MIT undergraduates and you can
see that there's a group of brain
regions shown here in the bright colors
that show more metabolism when these
undergraduates are thinking about other
people's thoughts
compared to when they're thinking about
other logical problem-solving just to
reassure reassure all of you and me we
did recently do this with real adults
and it works just the same I'm going to
talk today about one of these brain
regions that I've been studying quite a
bit which is called the right
temporoparietal Junction it's above and
behind your right ear and this brain
region seems to be playing some very
specific role in the human capacity to
think about other minds I'm just to give
you a sense of how reliable this is
these are the brains of just three
individuals who walked in off the street
we gave them 12 stories to read about
beliefs 12 stories to read about other
things and in each one you can see the
same little brain region that's lighting
up this is kind of amazing from a
neuroscientist perspective because that
kind of reliability having the same
brain region show up in each individual
who walked in off the street is the kind
of thing we'd seen before for visual
brain regions that let us see for motor
control brain regions that control our
actions but it's really rare to see
something that's systematic and reliable
for a function as complicated and as
abstract as thinking about other
people's thoughts one of the things that
we've been doing now is studying how
these brain regions grow in the life of
a child so as you saw there's reason to
believe based on the development that
these brain regions are at least their
functions are maturing really slowly
over the time course of development and
so we can take advantage of that to try
to watch that development happen in real
time this is a project we just started
this year
we scanned our first group of children
and here's the feedback we got from one
child
we showed him his brain he said
afterwards I discovered my brain fills
up my whole head I'm really smart
another child gratifyingly said I can't
wait to go again which is actually
wonderful much more enthused than the
MIT undergrads were this is them these
are the children sitting in front of our
practice scanner where they practice
being in that environment and what we
know so far is that first of all the
same brain regions are we can see them
in children thinking about somebody's
thoughts as we do see an adult so that's
good we can find these brain regions and
study them but interestingly they're not
exactly the same in the children as they
are in the adults so what I'm going to
show you here is just a measure of how
specialized this brain region is does it
do does it really do just thinking about
other people's thoughts or does it do
some related other things as well and so
this is gonna be on a scale from zero
not at all specialized to a hundred
percent specialized and in adults this
brain region is almost entirely
specialized for thinking about other
people's thoughts it does almost nothing
else but an eight and a half to eleven
year olds it's somewhat less specialized
and between five and eight and a half
year olds that's even less specialized
so well we can find this brain region
and start to study it it seems like it's
very very slowly acquiring this highly
specialized function in the human
cognitive life so that's very intriguing
and one of the things we're hoping to
follow up in the next few years but
another thing we've been looking at is
in the adults we've been looking not
just at when does this brain region get
recruited but also what does its
recruitment its activity predict in
terms of more complicated or real-life
decisions that people might be asked to
make and so in particular we wanted to
ask adults to make moral judgments just
like we asked the children and see if we
could see this brain region predicting
the kinds of moral judgments that people
would make and so we designed again this
is a grownup version of the Pirates
problem that you saw before and this one
might even be set at MIT and so in this
problem participants again will be lying
in the scanner and they'll read a story
like this grace and her friend are
taking a tour of a chemical plant and
while they're on tour they stop for
coffee and grace is making the coffee
and her friend asks for some sugar in
her coffee and
to the coffee machine is a jar of white
powder and this white powder is actually
a deadly poison but the jar is labeled
poison so grace thinks that the powder
is poison grace puts the powder in her
friends coffee her friend drinks it and
dies and the participants are asked was
it morally permissible for grace to put
the white powder in her coffee
now just to check does anyone think it
was morally permissible because if so
I'm getting my coffee somewhere else
okay so we can change little versions of
the scenario and ask a slightly
different question so for example in
some cases the jar might be labeled
sugar so it's a white powder next to the
coffee in a jar labeled sugar in that
case when grace thinks the powder is
sugar that's pretty reasonable and now
she puts it in her friends coffee and
her friend dies and we asked the
participants was it morally permissible
for grace to put the powder in her
friends coffee and hopefully more of you
now think it maybe was morally
permissible for grace to put the powder
in the coffee now again we can do it the
other way
the white powder by the coffee might
actually be sugar but be labeled deadly
poison and in that case when grace puts
the pattern her friends coffee her
friend is fine but we can still ask was
it morally permissible for grace to put
the powder in her friends coffee and
again I hope you have the intuition that
it wasn't morally permissible and so
these are the moral judgments that we
collected from participants when we just
asked them these kinds of questions so
what I'm gonna show you here are across
the bottom are the cases where the
friend is fine versus when the friend is
when the friend dies and the blue bars
are when grace thinks the poison the
powder of sugar and the red bars are
when grace thinks the powder is poison
so if the powder really is sugar and
grace thinks that it's sugar everybody
says it was morally permissible to put
it in the coffee that was totally okay
but if grace thought the powder was
poison even though it really was sugar
people say it was completely wrong to
put it in the coffee even though nothing
bad actually happened and by contrast if
grace thought of a sugar
even though she killed her friend by
accident people say it was mostly okay
not entirely okay but mostly okay to put
that in the French coffee and then in
the case where it was poison and she
knew it was poison people say it was
definitely not okay to put it in the
coffee which is good news and so now we
can look at well what's going on in
people's brains while they're making
these decisions and in particular we
took the one most interesting case in
some respects was the case where grace
accidentally poisoned her friend so she
sought the powder of sugar but then her
friend died and when we asked this
question how much should grace be blamed
for accidentally poisoning her friends
people actually sort of disagreed some
people she should say she should be
blamed not at all some people say she
should actually be blamed somewhat and
we can look at well what's going on in
this brain region in those people while
they're making that decision so what I'm
going to show you is different people
each person is going to be a dot along
the bottom I have put how much activity
there was in this brain region and then
on the vertical is how much blame did
they say that grace deserves so if they
say more blame that'll be higher up less
blame that'll be lower down and so what
you can see is that people whose are TPJ
this brain region had lots of activity
were the same people who are really
paying attention to Grace's belief but
she thought that it was sugar and saying
she deserved very little blame so they
at that the far that far end they have
very high activity in this brain region
and they assigned very little blame
paying most attention to the belief
whereas on the far left side we have
people who have very little activity in
this brain region and there are the
people who are paying very little
attention to the belief they're saying
she deserves a lot of blame because her
friend died so it looks like activity in
this brain region predicts quite a
consequential fact namely how much moral
judgment people will assign how much
moral blame people will assign for
accidents but of course a much stronger
proof that that's really what's going on
in this brain region would be not just
to observe that correlation but to
directly interfere with function in that
brain region and try to see if we could
thereby interfere with those moral
judgments there's basically two ways
that you can interfere with the function
of a human brain region
one is that you can wait for a case of
injury so you can wait for a case where
I've put a gunshot wound or stroke that
selectively impairs that brain region
but another way you can do it is a
technology called transcranial magnetic
stimulation that allows us to pass a
magnetic pulse through the skull into a
healthy individual and transiently
disrupt the function of that brain
region so I'm going to show you a video
of TMS the first thing I'm going to show
you is I'm trying to show you that it's
a magnetic pulse so the first thing
you'll see is me putting a quarter on
the coil that delivers the pulse and
then you'll hear a click sound the click
sound is when the machine goes off and
when the machine goes off you'll see
what it does to the quarter okay it's
quite an effective way to fling quarters
so now we're gonna apply that same
magnetic pulse to my skull
and because it's not easy to see moral
judgment we're gonna do it to the part
of the brain that controls my right hand
so this is marina positioning the coil
over my skull and she's using this brain
image of my brain to figure out where
she should position it so that she can
get it located over the part of my brain
that controls my right hand and then
again you'll see what happens to my hand
yep
ready yeah we're trying to get me to
fling the corner alright so you can see
that whenever the pulse goes off it
causes a small but significant
contraction of the muscle in my right
hand by causing the those brain cells
that control my right hand to fire so
now we can do a similar thing to people
who are making moral judgments in this
case of course we're not going to change
their right hand we're gonna try to
interfere with this brain region that
they use for thinking about other
people's thoughts so what I'm showing
you here are the moral judgments of
these same people while they're
receiving TMS but they're receiving it
to some other brain region a pre
newsroom we don't hypothesize to have
any role in moral judgment and as you
can see they're making pretty much the
same judgments that I showed you before
the judgments are so they say it's okay
for the blue bars when she thinks that
his sugar not okay for the red bars when
she thinks that it's poison and it
doesn't make as much of a difference
whether the friend was fine or does it
matters more what great stuff so now we
can ask well what happens to those moral
judgments if we've been applying TMS to
this brain region the right
temporoparietal Junction and so the
first thing is we don't interfere with
their ability to do the task at all and
so this is their moral judgments while
that after TMS to the right TPJ when
grace thinks the powdered sugar and it
is sugar and those judgments are
unaffected but now if we take the case
where grace thought that it was poison
but it was really sugar and her friend
was fine normally people say that was
really totally not okay she thought it
was poison and so it was really not okay
to put it in the coffee but after TMS -
there are TPJ they say it was
significantly more okay so it was more
okay for her to put what she thought was
poison in her friends coffee as long as
it wasn't really poison and then we have
the opposite case where she thought that
it was sugar but it was really poison
and people say that's adults say it's
mostly okay to put something you think
is sugar in the coffee even if it turns
out to be poison remember that's not
what the five-year-olds say and so after
TMS to the RT PJ we can make adults look
more like five-year-olds they say it's
less okay to put something you think as
sugar
in the coffee if it's really poison when
she thinks it's poison and it is poison
they still know that that's really not
okay so what I hope you've learned from
my talk today about how the brain
invents the mind is in particular for
adults thinking about other people's
minds is amazingly easy given what we
know about how the brain functions and
prompts a big challenge to
neuroscientists to come up with an
explanation of how a bunch of neurons
wired together and firing together can
give our brains the amazing capacities
they have but it wasn't always easy the
discovery of other minds is a very slow
and protracted process in childhood I
say slow but sure because one of the
amazing facts is of course all children
come to it they just come to it slowly
and effortfully almost all children I
want you to remember that there are
special brain regions in the human brain
that seem to play some special function
in this task and in particular these
brain regions are an exciting place to
look for figuring out how neurons
accomplish this job that this brain
region matures slowly over the course of
childhood in fact even the 11-year olds
that we studied don't have fully mature
brain theory of mind reign regions and
finally that by changing this aspect of
their brain function we can also change
your mind in this case the moral
judgments that you make but I want to
give the last word to the novelists and
parents and teachers and spouses via
Philip Roth an American pastoral who
concludes after the question that I
started with that the fact remains that
getting people right is not what living
is all about anyway it's getting them
wrong that is living getting them wrong
and wrong and wrong and then on careful
reconsideration getting them wrong again
[Applause]
Thank You Rebecca that that was quite
fascinating and by the way I'm very much
impressed with what it generated in
terms of questions quite a few I I hope
I hope we can have time to use some of
these let me let me ask you this one
first
does the development of the brain as we
grow up tell us about how the brain
evolved in some ways we assume so and in
some ways we hope so
and in some ways probably not so the way
in which we assume so is there's an old
principle of biology that development or
ontogeny the course of development of an
individual organism in some sense
recapitulates phylogeny recapitulates
evolutionary history so this is an idea
that will be familiar to people and who
know that for example a fetus in a very
early stage of development has a tail
right there so there's aspects of
evolutionary history of an organism that
are encoded in the development of that
organism and so in some sense we could
hope that that process and those
signatures continue on all the way
throughout development and so by
studying what develops first versus what
develops later we might be able to study
something about what was evolutionarily
old or what was evolutionarily new so
that's the sense that we and we assume
so is that by extension on a biological
principle and the the second answer is
that we hope so or rather that it's an
empirical question so insofar as we can
we're trying to simultaneously study
both development and the evolutionary
history of the human brain and see where
do those two independent empirical
programs converge on a similar answer so
one case is in these brain regions that
I study
I showed you evidence that functionally
they mature very slowly in the course of
childhood another thing about those
brain regions is that they are among the
most expanded in the human brain
relative to other mammalian brains and
so it seems like those two independent
empirical clues can help us zero in on
the mechanism of evolution and the
mechanism of their function and then the
third sense probably not is that another
aspect that of course hugely influences
child development is culture and
parenting and all the the environmental
factors that govern the growth of
children and those factors will surely
influence the way that their human brain
develops and in ways that can't
perfectly recapture the evolutionary
environment I hope I can do all of these
justice here's the next one is is the
art TPJ ever found on a person's left
side that's an interesting question
and so the when we look for all the
brain regions in the brain that seemed
to be playing some special role in
thinking about other people's thoughts
there's a brain region on each side one
on the right and one on the left and in
the people that we study we see that the
right the brain region on the right is
more specialized for thinking about
other people's thoughts than the one on
the left now
we by design study only right-handed
people that's because most right-handed
people so all human brains pretty much
have slightly different functions on
their right and their left and for most
right-handed people language functions
are on the left and for left-handed
people it's 5050 and so when we're
trying to study things that might be
different on the right on the left we
study right-handed people because we
think that will give us the best bet of
seeing consistency from one participant
to another my left-handed friends are
actually very annoyed by this they never
get to have their brain scanned and but
so we mostly study right-handed people
and in those people the right region
seems to be more specialized so we don't
know could we see the opposite and
left-handed people that's one question
another interesting observation from
language which is
better understood than social cognition
and is so if an adult damages their left
hemisphere the brain regions on their
left that support language and the adult
loses the capacity to speak and
understand language if you a massive
stroke in your left hemisphere severely
damages language production and language
comprehension but if an infant has the
same kind of stroke around the time of
birth in fact sometimes infants are born
was almost no left hemisphere whatsoever
those infants can acquire normal
language and that language function is
supported by the right hemisphere and so
it seems like around the time of birth
the two hemispheres although the left is
the preferential target of language the
two hemispheres are more balanced in
terms of what they have the capacity to
acquire and it's through the course of
maturation that these functions get a
sign sort of more permanently to one
side or another and so there's every
reason to believe although new direct
evidence that in a child with a massive
stroke to their right hemisphere that
they could in fact acquire normal social
cognition on the left as long as that
damage happened early enough in life and
but that's only an inference there's no
direct evidence of that yet these the
questions keep coming and they're really
quite good I'm not sure we can get
through all of them but there there are
several questions about the impact or
the study of autistic people and I think
what I do is just combine two questions
here and you can kind of work on it as
you as you like any thought as the
writer says here any thought to studying
autistics in in this area the second one
says people with some forms of autism I
believe it's called Asperger's
Asperger's syndrome lacked the ability
to read in indications from others faces
have you studied studied the brains of
these people yeah this is a great
question so one of the reasons that the
ability to think about other my
became a target of a neuroscientific
investigation not just a psychological
investigation was the observation that
children without with Asperger's and
autism have selective difficulty on the
kind of false belief problems that I
showed you these three children solving
and so very soon after those tasks were
first invented scientists in England
observed that kids with autism and
Asperger's had unusually had unusual
difficulty with those problems relative
to very similar logical problems and
that was the first indication that there
might be separate parts of the brain
responsible for solving those problems
that could then be separately disabled
by disease and so it's been an interest
along in the process of studying how
these brain regions function in typical
adults - also in typical children to
also understand the time course of a
typical development so the study that I
showed you where we were scanning
typical children was actually just the
very beginning of a large program
project that I'm doing in the department
of brain and cognitive science with my
collaborators professors Nancy kanwisher
and John Gabrieli and supported by the
Ellison Medical Foundation and the goal
is a massive study of typical
development and development with autism
were aiming to study a hundred typically
developing children and a hundred
children with autism and to specifically
look at the development of these brain
regions between the ages of five and ten
of course the hope is that since these
brain regions are related to thinking
about other people's thoughts and that
children with autism seem to have a
selective difficulty in thinking about
other people's thoughts we'll be able to
identify the neural basis of that
difficulty and then maybe use these
brain responses either as a measure of
interventions like a way of measuring
whether interventions are successful or
as a target of interventions a way of
deciding what will be an effective
treatment for autism and so that's
definitely part of our plans for the
immediate future there's there's quite a
bit of interest in how your research
might be applied to different categories
of people and with this one I
give a plea to perhaps be very careful
in the way that you state a question the
question is what difference does sex
play in your findings I think what the
person meant to say was what what
difference does gender play in your
findings I guess I shouldn't be making
MIT jokes in response to that question
right so we're very interested in
whether in the the broader question
there so I talked a minute ago about
disease about whether the differences in
this brain region is related to
differences that cause disease but
there's another question which is are
differences in these brain regions
related to just differences among
individuals differences between people
all of whom count as normal especially
around here and and so there's many
dimensions of differences between people
that might be related to differences in
in brain function I mean of course all
differences in personality are going to
come to down to differences in brain
function in one way or another and so
we've recently started a sort of survey
where so by now we've collected the
these brain regions the theory of mind
brain regions we call them from almost a
thousand people over the course of the
last ten years
and belatedly we're now starting to
collect a lot more information about
those people as we're scanning them so
of course age and gender but also
personality trait information and
psychiatric history and we're interested
in whether we can see correlations
between differences between people and
differences in the function of these
brains so until recently I always said
that I'd never seen a gender difference
in these brain functions and that that
was certainly true in the smaller
samples we were looking at but now that
we've started to look at a much bigger
sample we actually are starting to see
small gender differences and related
actually to differences reported
differences in empathy between
individuals and the difference is
interesting it's
that on a personality questionnaire
women report greater empathy on average
than men and that's related to this
brain region has actually worked as well
showing greater activity which you can
interpret as working harder in people
with lower empathy than in people with
higher empathy and so as a consequence
its we see more activity in men than
women but that difference is totally
explained by the empathy difference and
so once you match people for their
reported empathy that men and women
still look the same thank you I'm gonna
work a little bit on this theme of
different categories of brains this is
one that clearly was proposed by someone
who must be close to me in age it says
have you researched what happens to this
decision-making or capability in much
older Minds do is there a deterioration
of understanding in making moral
judgments I'm so in this room so we've
been looking at it a little bit and in
various different ways we have looked at
moral judgments on our moral questions
in younger and older participants in
that case we found that the older
participants tended to be a little bit
more punitive they tended to say you
know if you killed your friend well a
little worried and but for the most part
when we look at the brain functions
what we see is actually striking
similarity in the location and function
of these brain regions from the
five-year-old's we've studied up to the
60 year olds that we've studied recently
we've begun studying more grownups
partly because we we've started studying
congenitally blind adults we were
interested in how these brain regions
developed in people who had never seen
another person's face never seen a human
action and we were interested in whether
that would cause these brain regions to
develop early differently
suggesting that their development
depends on seeing people or whether
actually these brain regions might
develop very similarly if it's just
thinking about other people that's
necessary because blind children
certainly think about other people just
as much as sighted children so we were
scanning a population of adults who were
born blind and they ranged in age from
thirty to sixty and so we also scanned a
group of sighted people who ranged in
age from thirty to sixty and so as I
mentioned the the older adults the older
sighted adults showed the same brain
regions with very similar functions as
the five to ten year olds that we had
been scanning really interestingly so
did the congenitally blind adults so in
these adults who've never seen anybody
and these brain regions still have
exactly the same position and function
as in somebody who got visual exposure
to other people there are a number of
again situation situational categories
that people are wondering if that's
given you different different experience
different experimental outcomes the the
questions are more or less around is
there a difference between left-handed
and right-handed people do you see any
difference in children or adults from
different social backgrounds or family
backgrounds that perhaps may have been
abusive or nurturing versus nurturing
and and finally maybe I'll lump together
with this and you can handle it as it as
it makes sense when psycho sociopaths
are studied are their brains different
in terms of this recognizing or
understanding what's going on in in
other people's brains this is great I
feel like I'm being asked for my entire
undergraduate course
so a simple way to answer this question
would be to answer the most specific
version so to say in in terms of these
brain regions and this function what's
the difference for kids from different
backgrounds or for sociopaths versus
typical people and that that would be
easy to answer because the answer is we
have no idea we haven't done any of that
yet this is a new research program one
of the things I'm not sure I remembered
to say is that this technology in this
field is less than ten years old we're
just giving birth to an entire science
it feels like being in the Wild West you
know you can try anything nobody has any
idea what's gonna be the most productive
way to do this science yet which is a
really exciting time to be a young
scientist although occasionally gives a
sense of vertigo so when we look to
related fields where people have asked
these kinds of questions the most
related field is the developmental
psychology that I showed you in the
videos where you don't ask directly
about the brain development but you ask
about the development of the thinking
ability in children again from different
backgrounds or different groups there's
a few really intriguing hints in the
literature about that so one thing that
I find really intriguing is there's a
little bit of evidence that kids with a
really good ability to think about other
people's minds are actually somewhat
protected from the effects of parental
abuse so if you look at kids who start
out with either a really good ability to
think about other people's thoughts or
not so good ability and then you look at
the consequences for their lives of
living with abusive parents the kids who
were really good at thinking about other
people's thoughts are protected from the
negative consequences so that's very
intriguing in terms of thinking about
theory of mind among other things as a
self-protective or compensatory strategy
that lets us protect ourselves from
other people not just lets us engage
with other people one interesting way to
think about Psychopaths so there's a
little bit of neuroscience research on
Psychopaths actually this research is
always fun to read because they compare
psychopaths murderers to normal
murderers in our population of normal
murderers so when you look at that again
there isn't direct research on this
topic but the hints are that their
ability to know what other people are
thinking isn't impaired
what's impaired is their ability to care
and so it's interesting to think of
those as two different parts of the
problem one is sort of the problem
solving part figuring out what somebody
else's motivations would be and the
other part is being emotionally engaged
by that those might be supported by
different neural systems so I'll stop
there the questions were really very
interesting we can't get to the bottom
of them thank you very much for
responding to them and thank you very
much for the presentation
[Applause]
our next speaker is Pawan Sinha who is
an associate professor of vision and
computational neuroscience at MIT his
area of expertise is in understanding
how the brain recognizes objects in the
visual world this morning professorson
Hou will give us some insights into how
we learn to see professor Sinha welcome
[Applause]
thank you thank you it's a it's a true
privilege for me to be here and to be
able to share with you a journey that my
students and I have been on for the past
few years it's a journey that's in part
scientific and in part personal but it's
also a journey that illustrates how a
might've impact is felt in the lives of
people who might be thousands of miles
away from our campus so let me start by
introducing the people who have been
gracious companions these are my
students that's been Ballas who recently
graduated graduated with a PhD and that
regrettably is not the interior of my
lab it Myers Eaton is the one in the
middle
Scot Garlin not in India and Ming Ming
and euro scoffs ki Ming the postdoctoral
fellow who will be taking up a faculty
position at Dartmouth this fall and URI
is a graduate student who will be
finishing his ph.d this fall and here
they are pretending to be good Indians
in New Delhi and make Molson's with a
postdoctoral fellow and Tapan Gandhi who
is a doctoral student and in the middle
is one of our subjects so the journey
begins with a very simple observation
and that is that we are highly visual
creatures it's hard to imagine any
aspect of our interaction with the real
world that might not benefit from the
visual modality this has been the domain
that have interested us greatly and
specifically as Mead mentioned the
cushion of abiding interest to us and to
many scientists in the general domain of
neuroscience is how does the brain learn
to see this is the cushion that has deep
implications for many areas of
neuroscience and Beyond understanding
the process of development might help us
better understand the mature visual
system it might also help us develop
better diagnosis and interventions for
conditions that lead to problems in
visual processing and visual processing
might just be a gateway for
understanding many other kinds of
processing mechanisms in the brain the
brain might use the same kinds of
principles of operation not just for
vision but for other modalities as well
and finally very practically and as I
think Patrick will will exemplify
understanding the brain and how it
learns to see can help us make
autonomous
computer vision systems
so the cushion to my mind and to most of
our minds is undoubtedly important and
then the challenge becomes how can we go
about studying this question so whenever
we talk about a problem of learning how
does the brain learn to do X or Y the
impulse is to work with this beloved
creature the human infant and to try to
study how an infant begins to acquire
different capabilities in our case
different visual capabilities this is
certainly a very direct way of
approaching the problem but it has all
the kinds of challenges that you might
expect babies are not interested in
being our experimental subjects they
would rather sleep than give us good
data and this is something that I
learned firsthand with the birth of Pam
and my son
this is Darius at the age of five days
so when Darius was born I thought this
is going to be such a goldmine of data
[Laughter]
but very quickly I was dissuaded of that
that idea both by Darius and by his
mother so this approach habits have its
challenges
what else can we do to study visual
learning one other approach is to work
with adults normal adults but to put
them in settings that they are
unfamiliar with to show them bizarre new
kinds of objects that we have designed
in our favorite computer graphics
program such as the one that you see
here and to ask them to learn to
recognize objects from this class and
this approach has yielded some
interesting insights but the results as
you might imagine are contaminated by
the tremendous amount of experience that
an adult is bringing to the table so
it's fair to say i think that the
approaches that we have on hand have
significant limitations an alternative
approach if this to work with children
who have sight onset late in life so
what kinds of children might these be
these would be children who have been
allowed to remain blind for several
years even though their blindness is
treatable so certainly we cannot
ethically create a population of the
children but we can perhaps rely upon
some quote unquote natural experiments
finding individuals who for one reason
or another have been left blind have
been left untreated even though their
condition was curable the problem with
this approach is that such cases are
extremely rare I mean they're almost
impossible to find in fact it's
estimated that over the past millennium
fewer than 20 such cases have been
studied in any detail so it's hard to
come up with a sister
maduk scientific program using this
approach and now with the greater
development of medical resources
especially in the West these cases are
getting harder and harder to to locate
so is this then just a thought
experiment something that's fun to
consider but hard to implement and for
me too it was just a thought experiment
until I began to look a little closer at
the country I grew up in that's India
and what I discovered was somewhat
startling and I want to share with you
some of the facts and figures about
childhood blindness in India and what
I'm going to tell you is going to be
somewhat of a sobering counterpoint to
the stories that you might have been
become might have become more familiar
with from the popular press about the
growing economic clout of of India so
childhood blindness or blindness in
general in India is it's a massive
problem India has the world's highest
number of blind children well over a
million children are blind the incidence
of childhood blindness is well over
three times that in the developed
countries and if you include adults as
well then it's estimated that over one
in every hundred Indians is blind what
are the causes of childhood blindness in
the country there are several causes
here are the two primary ones corneal
scarring caused by things like vitamin A
deficiency have you see on the left and
congenital cataracts children being born
with the condition that we typically
associate with old age and there are
several other causes as well some of
which are listed here anomalies of the
entire eyeball anomalies of the retina
and so on and some somewhat shockingly
some traditional remedies
what do I mean by that what happens is
that many villages in the country are
completely devoid of medical care so a
medicine man who really does not have
any background in in medicine he takes
on the responsibility of prescribing
treatments and these treatments very
often do more harm than good and I want
to show you one example of that here's a
3 year old girl who had congenital
cataracts she was brought to the
medicine man and instead of suggesting
that the girl will be taken to the
hospital for a simple cataract removal
surgery the the person decides to drive
the demons out of the child by burning
her abdomen with with hot iron rods so
that's that that's the level of
ignorance that we have to contend with
simple conditions like conjunctivitis
but just need eyedrops are worsened by
the kinds of concoctions that are put
into the eyes of the children and the
children go blind as a result so
considering all of these causes it turns
out that nearly 60% of all childhood
blindness in the country can be treated
or prevented but how much is actually
treated less than 20% and the reason for
that is there are several reasons one of
the primary ones is that most of the
current interventions most of the
current programs for treating blindness
are focused on adults and the quality is
extremely dubious and just to convince
you of that I show you here a few of the
headlines just from last year these are
outcomes of I camps treatment camps that
are organized by private or governmental
clinical teams to treat cataract or
other eye anomalies out in the field and
the success rate of these icons is is
bring or the lack of success rate of
silvering this is just from 2008 there
are several other causes of the
untreated of the vast population of
untreated children fewer than 10% of all
India's hospital are equipped to do
paediatric surgeries most of the
ophthalmologists are concentrated in the
big cities New Delhi Bombay Calcutta
Madras while most of India's population
lives out in the villages and many are
desperately poor so they can't make
their way to the cities to get treatment
for the children this untreated
childhood blindness has devastating
consequences
kayson's death the life expectancy of a
blind child is 15 years shorter than
that of a sighted one and that's for the
lucky few who make it past early
childhood the childhood mortality rate
amongst the blind is over 50% fewer than
50% of the children who are blind make
it past the age of five less than 10
percent of these children get any kind
of education and less than 1% are
employed as adults so India suffers a
tremendous economic loss if one were to
think of this just in a purely mercenary
manner India is suffering a loss of to
the tune of 10 billion dollars a year
which is more money than what's needed
in order to tackle this problem at the
root but that's not happening and the
problem stays with us so it's clear that
there is a humanitarian need that needs
to be addressed and it also became clear
to me when I saw these facts and figures
that the humanitarian need was in
perfect synergy with the scientific need
I had mentioned of finding a child who
can have sight onset late in life so
this perfect synergy between the
humanitarian and the scientific missions
led us to launch project Prakash
Prakash is the Sanskrit word for light
and we hope that through this project we
can bring light into the lives of
children and also simultaneously shed
light on many of the deep problems of of
neuroscience the humanitarian goals of
project Prakash are the obvious ones we
want to provide treatment to as many
children as we can and also to build
awareness amongst the villagers and
amongst the doctors in the cities ask
you the magnitude of the problem we
started out fairly modestly on the
Samana Tyrian mission I would go out to
villages every summer or winter whenever
I had had to India from MIT
sometimes they compete by my father who
most of the villagers thought was the
real doctor and I was the assistant and
my father would go along with that so I
would examine these children and with my
limited knowledge of the ophthalmology I
would try to identify cases of of
treatable blindness and take them to to
the hospital for treatment so it was
well intentioned but a very minor effort
given the magnitude of the problem so
over the past couple of years as the
project has gained a little more
traction
we have enlisted the support of
hospitals in India and have gotten them
to launch outreach initiatives where
teams of medical workers can go out into
villages or into schools for the blind
and examine many children in one one one
go and I want to show you a short video
clip of one of these examination
sessions or screening sessions this is
from a school for the blind in New Delhi
[Music]
the piece of microfilm on an eyeball
that's too small
that's an extreme case of micros almost
all NFL most
it's hard even to discern the presence
of an eyeball these are permanent cases
of blindness we cannot read these cases
but every so often we come across
children who show sensitivity to light
or the ability to tell what direction
light's coming from and that's the first
indication that the condition and might
be beautiful
so after the field examination we bring
the children over to the hospital this
is one of the hospital
the hospital had world-class pediatric
facilities developed in part because of
a donation from the Ronald McDonald
foundation so you see many posters of
Happy Meals in in in the pediatric way
[Music]
I don't know whether the lighting is
good enough but as we zoom into the eyes
of this child you will see the whites
inside his pupils and those are
congenital cataracts and the nystagmus
is the searching eye movements that
you've seen and that indicates that the
the blindness had a very early onset
within the first three or four months
the hospital has a good surgical
facility for children and now you're
going to see the same child three weeks
post operatively we've removed the
bandages from his right eye
said we've conducted many such screening
camps and treatments mostly centered
around Delhi and overall well these are
some of the preoperative and
post-operative photographs of three
children
we have screened well over a thousand
children and provide a treatment to over
200 of them
[Applause]
thank you and there are also some other
intangibles that we've been able to
achieve like bringing the problem of
childhood blindness on to the radar
screens of the people who can make
policies so the members of parliament
questions about childhood blindness have
been raised in the in the parliament
directly because of the work that we've
been doing and the Supreme Court of
India has now mandated that every child
before being admitted to a school for
the blind has to go through has to be
examined by a registered ophthalmologist
so they are no needlessly blind children
who are ensconced in in schools for the
blind
that's the humanitarian side of project
Prakash the scientific aspect of the
project is to understand how vision
develops after the onset of sight so
what we do in a sense is this let's say
we find a child who has light
sensitivity or the ability to see what
direction light's coming from and we
judge that this is a treatable case of
blindness the child is provided with
treatment and this is the treatment is
entirely unconditioned on any agreement
on the child's or the families part to
participate in the scientific studies so
we treat many more children than the
children that we actually work with
there is no ethical dilemma about quid
pro quo
after the child is treated every week or
so we have the child run through a
simple battery of visual tests to try to
see what is the arc of visual
development that they are exhibiting
which visual abilities are coming on
first and which are the ones that are
following and this arc of development
provides us a very rich source of
information about detecting potential
causal dependencies between the early
developing skills and
later developing months and we do this
follow-up for as long as it's
practically possible
in order to determine what are the
asymptotic levels of skills that these
children have and what kinds of skills
are they perhaps permanently compromised
at and that's very important to know in
order to develop the right kinds of
targeted rehabilitation procedures very
recently we have gained access to a
functional brain imaging system in New
Delhi and now we can combine our
behavioral assessments with neuroimaging
assessments so we can begin to make
structure function correlations we can
see as a child is acquiring or is
exhibiting a particular proficiency what
are the aspects of brain function that
have changed perhaps in order to bring
about that behavioural change some of
the milestones that we've achieved so
far this is a fairly young project as
projects go we've been doing this for
about three or four years so our
accomplishments are I would say modest
but we are proud of the of the little
bit that we've done so far one of the
big dogmas in neuroscience that comes to
us from work with animals is the dogma
of critical periods that if the brain is
deprived of sensory information for the
first few months or first couple of
years of life the brain is not going to
be able to make use of that information
even if that sensory modality is
restored and what we are finding is that
that's just not true even individuals
who are treated in adulthood so they've
been blind until the age of twenty or
thirty you restore vision and they can
acquire very significant visual function
so this is beginning to challenge one of
the main ideas in neuroscience some of
the specific data that we've gotten
about the time course of object learning
has allowed us to develop computational
models
of visual learning this is the paper on
the development of face learning in in
these children and very recently we have
also begun to tackle some long-standing
philosophical questions here's one of
the the big ones it's referred to as the
Molyneux problem over 300 years ago
Molyneux framed the cushion imagine that
you have a person who has grown up line
and while blind this person has learned
to tell the difference between a cube
and a sphere by touch and now through
some miracle as an adult the person
gains sight and you put the cube and the
sphere in front of front of the person
would this person without touching the
cube in the sphere be able to tell which
is which
this has deep implications for the
empiricist and the the nativist
viewpoint and also issues of how shape
or information in general is encoded
across different sensory modalities this
question has remained open for the past
three centuries and with project Prakash
for the first time we have data to
actually answer this question so any
guesses as to what the answer is how
many of you think that the answer is a
yes that the person will be able to tell
immediately okay so that's about 50%
that's exactly the right kind of answer
I wanted so about half of you think that
the answer is yes yes and the other half
presumably think the answer is a even no
so it's an interesting question to ask
them it's not a foregone conclusion we
find that the answer is a no immediately
after sight answered children are
entirely a chance at transferring the
haptic knowledge to the visual domain
but interestingly enough give them a
week and they can do this at ceiling
level at a hundred percent so even
though they are at chance on day one on
day seven
they're at 90 or 100 percent so what it
was happening in the brain is happening
very very rapidly and we are currently
trying to understand what are the
mechanisms of such rapid learning our
work has been profiled in a few
scientific and popular venues here's an
article from nature and here's one from
Time magazine and this is gratifying
because ministers in the Indian
government are not reading journals like
neural computing or or even nature they
are reading things like time so for us
to be able to go to them with these
articles it's a much greater it carries
much more weight than going to them with
a stack of scientific papers so it gives
us more leverage one of the the projects
that we have been working on recently
that I wanted to tell you about just in
a little more detail because it touches
on a few other directions in the lab if
the is the project related to visual
integration and let me first illustrate
what the problem is that we're tackling
this complex landscape that you're
observing is an image where I have
represented the brightness of each point
in the image with height so the hills
and valleys correspond to how bright or
dark the corresponding region of the
images and I've done that just to make
the point that in an image they are no
easy cues for telling you where one
object ends and the other one begins if
I were to ask you to parse this in two
distinct objects it's a very difficult
task and yet we do this all the time
so what you see on the bottom left is
the original image and it's easy for us
to say where the boundaries of different
objects are even though the information
that we are getting it's extremely
complex how does the brain learn to do
this task of visual integration of
putting together
the world into meaningful chunks here's
another way of saying the same thing
given any image such as the one you see
on the left in the fine-structure this
image is made up of many different
regions of different colors different
brightnesses somehow the brain can put
together subsets of these regions and
come up with meaningful assemblies and
we are interested in understanding how
this happens and we are using project
Prakash in order to gain some insights
into this developmental process
I'll show you data from three children
because they span a nice age range from
seven to 229 but we have gotten similar
data from about 13 additional children
so we feel very confident about what I'm
going to dimension so after these
children were treated
we had them run a very simple battery of
visual tests probing their ability to to
parse a world meaningfully or parse the
images meaningfully so I'm sure it's
hard to see in the back but this is an
outline of a circle overlapping a square
or a filled circle overlapping a
transparent square and so on a colored
square overlapping another colored
square so we showed show the children
these images and we asked him to say how
many objects do you see where are they
if you can name these objects please
name them and the results that we get
are amazingly consistent across
different children irrespective of age
so here's a short video of the 29 year
old four weeks after treatment trying to
interpret these images
a chatty next week
okay triangle next yeah
Square thank you can
yeah
but if they continue
if keen um but I don't want it sitting
here
[Music]
square and circle
let's make it peachy than
only say Jared Tino Tino Tino Tino
k-beach made upon the rocky but I Iike
haka I met in G H I take a Sutra take a
check above only they only paid per day
it's visual motor coordination is kind
of poor but you can get the sense of
roughly what is Thank You paisa
that's it
tea yes my brother he could meet you
there it's very thankful to each other
I said yeah I've been there Tonio saying
this man but I agree it's me it's like
one of my graduate students suggested
that even if he had said yes we would
have subtitle this no we wouldn't
so it's interesting he was able to to
recognize the triangle when shown on its
own but when embedded in the field of
lines here he fails and just to put some
numbers for control subjects these tasks
are trivial they are at feeling at
hundred percent performance on all of
these tasks these subjects are at floor
they perform very consistently but they
don't parse the world quite as we would
parcel so they are all at zero percent
and in fact with three-dimensional
objects when we asked them how many
objects do you see are there they just
see it as three different objects the
world is broken up into many pieces in
the tray things you get the same sense
of over fragmentation so given the black
figure SK is tracing it as two L's and
one little thing in the middle and here
is another child I've asked him to do
copy this shape
chicken very good or if Cupid of the
capable and now I'm asking him to trace
on the one the star itself and what I
want to point out is just how piecemeal
that tracing strategy is every little
segment in that figure is being traced
as a separate entity
okay
what does this have to do with
real-world recognition so we showed
these children images of commonplace
objects and what we found was that the
recognition rates were fairly low
ranging from 18 percent to 34 percent so
very few of these images are being
recognized and will have a little more
to say about this in just a moment
when so the images that they are unable
to recognize if you ask them to point to
where the objects are even if they can't
name the objects they point to each
region of a different color or luminance
so for the cow each black splotch
becomes its own object in fact for a
ball even the shadow becomes its own
object so the world is broken up into
many little pieces and the brain seems
to be unable to put all these pieces
together however if we introduced a
different kind of a visual cue the
performance changes our decree
guess what you saw earlier can't make it
and now Ethan has set it in motion
right
I said you have to teach it ahead to
take but it's 18 people die
please
but they need
oh yeah hey
so notice that the two figures are
always staying overlapped it's never the
case that we are completely separating
them and yet with motion almost a
magical change comes about just to
compare the performance without motion
which is that zero percent and with
motion they are going up to 60 or 70 or
80 percent so now back to the real world
recognition I said that the performance
was quite poor but it's still
interesting to ask given that the
recognition performance is not zero
there are some images that these
children are recognizing and others they
are not what is the difference between
the images that they do recognize and
the ones that they don't so here for SK
one of the subjects is the set of
recognized versus unrecognized images
outlined in red are the ones he's
recognizing and the others he is not and
just looking at these images it's not
immediately clear what's the what's the
difference between these two sets of
images they seem about equally complex
they're about as colorful so what might
be the rule and we didn't couldn't
figure out what the the possible rule
was until we began to see these results
from motion and then we asked how about
partitioning the set of images we are
showing these children in two images
that depict motile objects versus those
that depict a motile objects so if you
do that this is the partition that you
get in red are the images that people
would rate as being motile and in blue
are the ones that we would rate of being
in motile and if you compare the
recognised set for our subjects in red
are the ones that they're recognizing
and in blue other ones they're not
recognizing so it's a remarkable
congruence between the criterion of
motility and the recognition performance
statistically a very significant
congruence and we get the same
congruence for all of the children that
we have tested so far there are
exceptions of course
and this exception folds across all of
the children that we work with so here
is coca-cola Pepsi sure cookie butter so
I talked about MIT is impact this is the
impact of American marketing 6,000 miles
you can go to the remotest village in
India and they will be one hut that's
painted either entirely blue or entirely
red and that's the Coke or Pepsi
distribution site so here's the emerging
pattern of results from project Prakash
we find that the early stages of site
onset are invariably coupled with
integrative difficulties the world is
over fragmented these integrative
impairments we believe compromise
recognition skills but motion provides
important information regarding object
segregation and integration to begin
piecing together the world and motion
importantly also appears to create
representations of objects that can then
be used by the brain to recognize these
objects in static images so we can ask
are these the initial stages of a
learning program that will eventually
lead the brain to being able to parse
static images correctly or if this a
strange learning pathway that will never
allow these children the normal facility
that we have with static image parsing
and we didn't have a way of addressing
that cushion until we followed these
children several months after their
treatment so here is SK 18 months
postoperatively
and he can do some fairly complex ones
also but I wouldn't take the time to and
we find the same thing across all four
children the time at which they begin to
show these quote unquote normal skills
varies from child to child and it's
correlated with the age at which they
were treated but we find that the same
progression holds and these are just
data from a few children I'll skip
through this
so what tentative inferences can be
drawn from these these results the first
one is the if the obvious one just given
the fact that these children are
learning we need to rethink our notions
of of brain plasticity the idea that the
brain is plastic only in the initial
couple of years of life and then it
somehow loses its malleability that
seems to be to be discarded so and the
strict notion of critical periods seems
not to hold the second inference is the
more specific one given the privileged
position and the privileged role of
motion that we are observing and given
what's been reported in the infant
literature where babies first become
sensitive to motion cues well before
they become sensitive to any other kinds
of cues cues of color or brightness or
form the hypothesis that we are
formulating is that this privileged role
of motion is not by happenstance but
rather motion serves a critical boooooo
strapping function for visual learning
this is the building block over which
much of the rest of visual learning
rests ongoing work involves refining the
concept of critical periods so instead
of just applying this this blanket
notion of critical periods on all visual
skills we are trying to to figure out a
more nuanced version of this idea which
skills are subject to a critical period
and which are not and from the second
inference of the role of motion we are
taking two different directions one is
the development of a computational model
of visual learning this is a fairly
ambitious undertaking we are trying to
create a computational system that we
call Dylan whose goal is to take in
visual information essentially uh Nana
Tate a draw video of the same kind that
a baby or a child in project Prakash
would get and begin to discover
automatically what is the what are the
meaningful chunks in this world so to
behave like a human child and the second
is some tentative work in in autism
quite surprisingly project Prakash is
leading us do some interesting
hypotheses in autism and I'll I'll wrap
up in just a couple of minutes but let
me mention what the tentative
connections are so here's what we find
from project Prakash that early stages
of site acquisition are accompanied by
integrative difficulties and the vast
literature in autism which suggests that
children with autism who might have
otherwise normal visual function
experience integrative difficulties in
analyzing visual and other sensory
information in project Prakash we find
that integrative impairments compromise
recognition skills and there are reports
from the autism literature suggesting
that autism is correlated with
recognition impairments
but most interestingly for us we are
hypothesizing in project Prakash that
motion plays a critical role for the
development of integrative skills and if
you look at the literature in autism a
few papers that have probed motion
perception have found that motion
perception is compromised significantly
compromised in autism so the working
hypothesis that we have is that at least
some correlates of autism might be
manifestations of integrative
impairments which might in turn be
caused by a basic limitation in dynamic
information processing and here's where
I'd like to request the lights to come
down I want to show you a couple of
examples of tests of motion perception
that we are conducting in in our lab
what you're going to see here is a first
a control subject playing pong our
home-brewed version of this video game
pong that hopefully many of you are
familiar with when I've given this talk
to some of the undergraduates they don't
even know what pong is
so so what you'll see is the child
controlling the paddle with the mouse
here's the ball that will bounce around
and in blue is our record of the child's
gaze they are they looking while they're
playing pong so what's interesting to
note is how anticipatory the gaze is
well before the ball hits the paddle or
the wall the child begins to you to look
to look at the point of impact so they
are able to make use of the motion
information so far to predict what the
trajectory is going to be in the future
and they can bring the paddle to the
right place in advance of the ball
actually getting there now let's look at
a similar kind of recording of I guess
from a child with autism
notice how often the child follows the
ball rather than anticipating the
trajectory and other experiments that we
are doing seem to bear out this idea
that the ability to integrate
information dynamic information over
time seems to be significantly
compromised in autism and I don't have
time to flesh out the implications of
that hypothesis but it makes connections
to many many aspects of the broader
autism phenotype so here's the causal
chain that we are developing in the
domain of autism we eventually want to
understand the hallmark deficits in
autism the social skill impairments but
we are trying to figure out what might
be factors leading up to it and at the
moment we find that or we hypothesize
that this is one of the key building
blocks that might underlie many
different aspects of of autism so
project Prakash have unexpectedly led us
to a potential hypothesis about an
impairment that might explain some
aspects of autism so to summarize
project Prakash has been this amazingly
gratifying project for us it has allowed
us to have to be able to contribute to
multiple aspects of our work certainly
in blindness alleviation it has provided
us insights regarding brain mechanisms
of plasticity and learning it has given
us some clinically relevant hypotheses
it has seeded our work in computational
modeling and the students who have been
involved with project Prakash the
postdoctoral students the graduate
students and their undergraduates have
all found this to be an important
component of their MIT training the
challenges for project Prakash are
significant if you think of this green
disc as all of the children that we have
treated so far
this is what we face so this is what
we've treated and this is the number of
children awaiting treatment so what
we're doing is now scaling up our work
by creating a Prakash Center for
children which combines healthcare
education and research all in one campus
so the idea if you have a hospital a
school where these children that we are
treating can be educated immediately
after there they are the gain side and
then we coupled that with an on-site
research facility and we've decided to
locate this in this little town called
Rishikesh in the foothills of the
Himalayas because it has good access to
the population centers of the country
this was the gans it explains which has
about 35 percent of India's population
and it's desperately poor and
desperately in need of of medical
facilities and it doesn't hurt that
Rishikesh looks like this so so every
summer it would be a pleasure to go over
there and do this work so let me
conclude by saying that project Prakash
has been an incredible opportunity for
us to not only tackle some interesting
neuroscience questions but also to
directly impact for the better the lives
of many children that we work with thank
you very much
I was really good
[Applause]
we have a bit of a dilemma here because
of time as the morning has gone on your
questions have gotten better and better
and it would be very interesting to ask
pull on these these questions but I'm
afraid we just don't have time where
we're going to have to hold ourselves to
two questions and it was very hard to
figure out which which ones because your
questions were in fact very good but let
me give you two and we will have to be
very brief because we we have a limit at
the end there there are two questions
about the difference between color and
shape and I'll try to combine them
[Music]
maybe I'll just read both of them does
background color affect what the the
person that you're studying sees it
seemed dark backgrounds were
recognizable light or white not
background the second the second aspect
of this and you have to handle them I
guess both together since color and
shape both represent different pieces of
one thing for people with restored sight
does levels of luminescence
of light hitting the object create a new
piece or shape from from the from the
whole of these people do you understand
what's being asked kind of perhaps make
it breathe okay I will make it brief but
the first question is easy to answer and
that has the background luminance even
though it's it's an interesting
observation given the images you saw
that maybe dark backgrounds are easier
objects are easy to recognize on dark
background stand on lighter ones we find
that that correlation does not hold we
have tested these objects on many
different kinds of backgrounds and that
does not matter what really matters is
the criterion of motility and as for the
second question perhaps the questioner
is asking does luminance play an
important role in the in the formation
of these of these representations and
indeed it does it interacts in an
important way with the dynamic
information so dynamic information links
together pieces that have stood out the
initial parsing into the regions is
based on luminance and then those pieces
get get glued together via motion it's
very interesting to see the impact of
dynamism or change motion in in your
work but I'm afraid we won't be able to
analyst there were a number of very good
questions querying whether the impact of
your study affected certain other
conditions that were more familiar with
for instance and maybe we just have to
make this one one or two of the examples
I'm sorry for that but we know that's
okay does your research lead to any
understanding of dyslexia or other
cognitive diseases that's that in
particular it's an interesting
connection dyslexia has been associated
with an abnormality in what's referred
to as the Magno system so processing
visual processing in the brain can be
roughly divided into the powerful system
and the Magno system with the Magno
system being more concerned with dynamic
processing and if they are a couple of
influential theories which suggests that
dyslexia might be related to an
impairment of the Magno system so we are
following that up to try to see whether
whether there is a connection between
the children we are studying and the
population of dyslexic children
professor son
thank you so much for your presentation
[Applause]
Patrick Winston is the Ford professor of
artificial intelligence and computer
science at MIT his area of expertise is
currently in how vision language and
motor facilities account for
intelligence this morning professor
Winston will tell us about about
computer about a computer with common
sense welcome Patrick
[Applause]
I am a member of a naval advisory
committee which takes me to San Diego
for two weeks each summer and I have the
great privilege therefore of visiting
the San Diego Zoo in fact two weeks from
today and about this time in the morning
I'll be making my entry into the San
Diego Zoo and my first stop will be the
orangutan I love watching the orangutans
because they're so human-like in how
they act and what they do and I
especially enjoy watching them stand on
four legs because as you can see their
back legs are really short and their
arms are really long and I look at them
and I say to myself if those fellows had
just pitched back a few degrees I would
be today speaking to a large hall filled
with people with long orange hair and we
would be the ones that would be in the
zoo's after I spent some time with the
orangutans of course I make my way to
the chimpanzees I especially feel
obligated to visit the chimpanzees
because they are our closest cousins and
when I started in my field we had no
idea how similar we are to chimpanzees
but now we do know we know that from a
DNA perspective we are chimpanzees -
about 97% or maybe it's 98% it keeps
going up I presume that it will
eventually I assume that eventually it
will fall short of reaching 100% so that
we can preserve a little of our
remaining dignity but I want to know why
I'm different from a chimpanzee and I'd
like to know why the humans that
populated our planet a hundred thousand
years ago were not like us even though
they look like us there was only about
fifty thousand years ago that we of the
human species began to do anything
interesting
after about fifty thousand years we
started building pyramids eventually
rewrote plays did mathematics built the
universities and somehow something has
made it different us different and I
like to understand what it is so I'll
spend my allocated time discussing that
with you and in the event that some of
it should seem dry I feel obligated to
make you a promise and the promise is
that when I'm finished you'll be smarter
than when I started
and by this I don't mean that you'll
just be more informed what I mean is
that you'll be smarter so let me proceed
then into the main part of the show I'll
start with a with a articulation of a
goal this is an aggressive goal and it
invites several questions one question
is why am I so optimistic another is
exactly what is a computational theory
of intelligence and a third is exactly
how long do you plan to live
for this the answer comes from biology
biology teaches us that the energy
producer in our cells are the
mitochondria we inherit the mitochondria
only from our mothers that's where all
the mitochondrial DNA comes from my
mother is 98 and determined to outlive
her sister who had 103 is still a moving
target so perhaps my claim is not as
outrageous as it might seem but honor
the question of why be optimistic one
reason to be optimistic about this
happening and having this happen at MIT
is because I sit at a round table with
colleagues like Rebecca and Paul Wong
and many others spread throughout the
Institute so we have at MIT the
ingredients for a great initiative
against the deep scientific question of
what is it that makes us humans
different from the chimpanzees what
makes us intelligent and of course we're
encouraging this kind of
cross-disciplinary activity because our
president is well known to have an
appetite for large efforts against
substantial social problems and
scientific inquiries well why are we in
artificial intelligence and computer
science at this table it's because our
perspective is a little different we
like to look at the problem of
intelligence from the perspective of the
kinds of well let me put it this way if
we're thinking about the difference
between a computer and a person there's
quite a lot of difference at the bottom
level computers are dry inside
we're wet inside they have transistors
we have neurons so down at that level
we're quite different at the
architectural liberal level we're still
quite a lot different our Anatomy is
different from that of a computer and
the architecture is different as Rebecca
and her colleagues continue to work away
at that problem we learned about the
kinds of things that are very different
in in our own Anatomy from what we would
expect to find in a computer
but eventually we reach the
computational level where we ask
computational questions how is it
possible to compute that what is the
nature of our universe that makes it
possible for us to see how far something
is what makes stereo vision vision
possible all these kinds of questions
are computational questions that have
computational answers that are to some
extent independent of the kinds of
apparatus that it's at the very bottom
level whether it's a neuron or a
transistor so we who do this kind of
work are interested in what are the
computational questions what are the
faculties by which humans think and how
can we understand those faculties at a
computational at a computational level
one of those faculties of course is
pawan is emphasized as our vision system
and here's the first of my major claims
we think with our eyes in the early days
of artificial intelligence we regarded
vision is merely an i/o channel but in
fact we think with our eyes it's not
just a n io channel if you're not sure
about that let me give you a puzzle how
many countries in Africa are on the
equator I don't imagine that many of us
would stake our life on our answer to
that question but let me ask you the
question again and now something
extremely remarkable is happening I've
used my language apparatus to
communicate with your language apparatus
and your language apparatus has
instructed your visual apparatus to scan
across that red line
counting the countries as it goes so
there's a remarkable ability of our
human language system to marshal and
direct the perceptual faculties that
seem not just there for IO but therefore
problem-solving
sometimes the kinds of things that we do
with our visual system deal with things
that aren't even there the things we
imagine so if I say to you for example
John kiss Mary and then I ask you a
question did John touch Mary
you all know that it must have happened
because you have some sort of image
blurry perhaps but you you see that
image of John and Mary locked in an
embrace and you and you can read the
answer off of the imagined image with
your visual apparatus so vision isn't
just an i/o channel it's the locus of
very profound kind of problem-solving so
as an engineer how do I think about it
well I think that if I can't build it I
don't fully understand it so using the
kinds of clues that I get from the rest
of the round table I and my colleagues
try to build systems that can see and
use a vision system not just as a
recognition apparatus not just as
recognition apparatus to recognize faces
or objects but but also as a
problem-solving mechanism so the kinds
of experiments the kinds of programs we
write our programs that look into the
world and assess what's happening out
there and here you see a photograph of a
student of ours Stephanie who is being
watched by a program who is trying to
figure out what she's doing and she's
going to do it she's going to jump and
so you'll see a bar light up just over
the jump arrow as she jumps and you see
that blue that's a program that's looked
into the world and decided that it's
seeing a jumping activity
here's another Stephanie's working with
her friend the friend is going to give
the ball to Stephanie Stephanie is going
to take it
so you'll see both give and take light
up there goes the ball and both give and
take light up because whenever you give
somebody something they take it from you
so that's an example of how we're trying
to take what used to be thought of as a
purely symbolic and linguistic kind of
enterprise and connect it to the
perceptual apparatus by which we
interact with the world so we think with
our eyes we also think with our hands
I'm not so sure about that but there are
examples you may have noticed in
Pollan's last movie that
subject he was working with doing a
great deal of tracing around those
objects with his fingers we seemed to
use our hands a lot when we think I I
once had a student by Z of mine who
developed a severe case of RSI
repetitive stress injury so she was all
locked up in a contraption with lots of
velcro and stuff and she couldn't move
her hands and I asked her if it really
impaired her her her work a great deal
and she said well it doesn't do anything
to my my humanities subjects because I
can always dictate my papers but the one
thing I can't seem to do is mathematics
I thought that was interesting she
couldn't move her hands and that
impaired her ability with mathematics
that's of course folklore at this level
but I was sitting at the commencement
exercises yes yesterday waiting for
something to happen and my colleague
Berwick starts telling me about
experiment recent experiments which have
been conducted with small children who
are learning mathematics and instructed
to use their hands as they work
mathematical problems that are akin to
algebra and the ones that were
instructed to use their hands do much
better than the ones who were not using
their hands so it seems an interesting
ways that we think with our eyes and we
think with our hands and of course most
significantly we think with our mouths
let me give you the experimental
evidence for that well first the
anecdotal evidence I was talking about
Danny Hillis well who a lot like like I
was once a graduate student working with
Marvin Minsky and Danny came into my
office one day and he said have you
noticed that Marvin has a short
attention span
I said yes I've noticed that he said
whenever I talk to him and try to
suggest an idea he's usually figured out
the idea within a couple of seconds and
I can't actually explain it
have you experienced this I said yes I
have and then he said have you noticed
that the idea that Marvin is guessing
you have is actually better than the
idea that you're trying to explain
[Laughter]
yes I've noticed that I said Eddie he
went on to suggest that he went on to
ask do you talk to yourself when you
solve problems and I said yeah sure I do
well what if that inner conversation we
have with ourselves is an important
problem part of the problem-solving
process if it's actuated mechanisms in
our minds brains that make it possible
for us to recall and use information
that we've learned him and taught that's
folklore let's look at some experiments
these are done by community of
psychologists most notably Liz spelke
who did some of the work that I'm about
to report when she was at MIT you
imagine a rat the rat is in a
rectangular room all the walls are
painted white I suppose that's why
they're black here all the walls are
painted white and while the rat is
watching some food is placed in a small
basket then the rat is spun around and
the question is where does the rat go to
look for the food and the answer is
that's pretty smart it only goes to two
of the four possible corners it goes to
the to where the food could actually be
after it's been disoriented so it's able
to use the shape of the room to decide
which of the two corners to go to now if
you substitute a small child you get the
same result usually you substitute a
small toy or something of that sort
instead of the food still goes to the
two corners and of course if you use an
MIT person well you can go back to food
again but you still get you still get
you still get the movement to the
opposite corners and all we've learned
so far is that from the perspective of
this experiment rats and people are
pretty much the same I like to tell my
students that were just rats with big
brains but now we repeat the experiment
with one wall point painted blue and for
us that breaks the symmetry so well what
happens to a rat
if you spin it around see where it goes
doesn't seem to use the blue wall even
if you even though if you put the food
in a blue basket it would have no
trouble whatsoever picking out the right
corner
but somehow it's having difficulty
combining the rectangular shape of the
room with that blue wall and amazingly
if you use that small child you get the
same result can't seem to use the blue
wall it's only the MIT professor that
figures this all out now there are some
questions that come up when you do these
and what is the what age does the small
child become an adult and the answer is
about five which is shockingly late I
think but you can ask the next question
is what is what characterizes at that
time when the child becomes an adult and
and and it's the exact age at which the
child has begun to use the words left
and right in their own descriptions of
the world and I had to say that
carefully because they understand left
and right at an earlier age but this is
the age when they start to use left and
right in their own descriptions of the
world it's if they have something in
their linguistic apparatus in their
language apparatus that makes it
possible to combine the information from
the blue wall with the information about
the shape of the room to get the answer
right but now there's one further thing
that's done with this sort of work you
now ask the adult to undergo the
experiment again but this time while the
adult is spinning around in a chair you
ask the adult to read something back to
you that you read to the adult at the
same time so it's a little bit like
simultaneous language translation only
it's English to English some people can
do this very easily some people take a
few minutes to get on to it but it's
something we can all do within a few
minutes if you do that with a human
adult you reduce them to the
a rat again somehow you've jammed the
language channel and the human adult
becomes no better than a rat at figuring
out where the food is since that's a
professor the undergraduates love it
so that's rats children and adults can
we make this more meaningful I'll tell
you something about some of the
experiments of Michelin Chi now I would
normally tell you about work performed
at another university but I'll make an
exception for Mitchell and she because
she happens to be married to a MIT
graduate and her son just picked up a
degree from president Hockfield
yesterday so Oh a lot myself to talking
about Mickey's work and I'll also allow
myself because it's I think very
instructive she has people work physics
problems you probably all remember 801
there are problems like that and she
instructs them and some are good at it
and some are not so good at it she
divides them into two groups the ones
that are good at it and the ones that
are bad at it and as they work problems
he has them talk out loud and she takes
the cat she makes a count of how often
they say things to themselves while
they're solving the problem some of the
knowledge is just plain problem-solving
knowledge like oh I'm stuck or I need
some help here other knowledge is
physics knowledge these forces must be
equal things of that kind
so taking into account the best and the
worst measuring how often they say
things to themselves the worst in the
invisible white font there on the
average talk to themselves and say
things themselves about 10 times in the
course of solving a problem what about
the ones who are best 35 times
so it seems that the students who are
good at this talk to themselves a lot
what we don't know is whether if an A
student is instructed to talk to
themselves a lot of fell do better but
it's certainly the case that the ones
that do do better have a tendency to
talk to themselves a lot so what do we
do about this as computer scientists
well where are mighty people so we make
models in fact I think that's the
distinguishing characteristic of an MIT
education we learn to make models of
everything 21:1 we'll make a model of
that too so if we're going to make
models of that what kind of models are
we going to make well what kind of model
is a model of what kinds of things we
humans say when we use language and
we've developed a system that has 18
different ways of capturing the meaning
of a sentence not just the syntactical
analysis but what this sentence actually
does by way of telling us about the
world many of these sentences are
sentences like that one the bird flew to
the top of a tree and you'll see light
up in yellow that's the trajectory
apparatus talks about movement along a
path talks about locations places types
of motion some of the conversation that
we have as we talk to other people is
about physical space and some of it is
about the movement along trajectories in
very abstract spaces so here country is
moving toward democracy that's about as
abstract a concept as you can get but
it's still from the perspective of this
system a movement of something along a
path in some kind of space when we have
that sort of thing understood when we
know what sentences do then we can think
about how we can build systems that use
their imagination to solve problems a
while ago I gave you the example of John
kissing Mary let me show you some recent
work work you wouldn't have seen if you
were here a month ago that suggests how
a computer might solve a problem with
its imagination now in order to make the
font big enough for you to see some of
the some of the text ability truncated
but
I hope it will be audible on the house
sound system so imagine that a ball
falls into a bowl okay imagine a better
ball falls into a ball so a synthesizer
has imagined the action of falling into
a bowl now here's an analogue to John
kissing Mary okay
I'm the magic mountain man runs into a
woman well this is we don't have much
very elaborate synthesizer but box will
have to do yes I have learned from
experience that contact between a man
and a woman appeared because a man runs
into a woman so because it has
perceptual apparatus that can solve the
problem with its perceptual apparatus of
course we're not limited to blocks we
can imagine other kinds of things okay
uh imagine about the man gives a ball to
a man these two slugs are graduate
former graduate students of mine now
distinguished faculty
you can even imagine things that can't
okay
I began the magic man-to-man flies does
it get very far but that's part of the
points so we think with our imagination
but think with our eyes we think with
our hands we think with our mouth we
think with our nation and we think with
stories I think that much much of
Education from childhood on is about is
about stories in the beginning we tell
our children fairy tales so they won't
run into the woods we scare the hell out
of them later on we teach literature in
history history because it's supposed to
repeat itself literature because it's
about the human condition and then we go
to professional school and we learn law
medicine business engineering science
all those subjects are largely taught by
the kinds of stories that we tell so the
question becomes can we using what we've
done so far with our visual system in
our language system and are all kinds of
systems imagine it'd be possible that a
program could capture the meaning that
comes across and in a story so here's a
not Macbeth but just the plot on Macbeth
and there are one or two things I'd like
you to especially notice in here there
are no there are no sentences containing
the word because so if the system is to
get anything out of the story it's going
to have to get it by applying some
background knowledge just general
knowledge about what goes on in the
world how do we know if it knows
anything well we can ask it questions we
can ask for example how's Duncan doing
at the end and it should know that he's
not doing very well because he's dead
we might say why did Macduff kill
Macbeth that's a little harder but to
answer that question would have to know
that if you kill somebody's friends you
harm them as well and then you might
elevate it to a higher level still and
say well now that I see you can
understand and fill in the gaps between
the explicit statements in the story can
you recognise concepts like revenge or
Pyrrhic victories so let me show you
what we've been able to do in the past
month or so this is this is what's in
the story this is not just a syntactical
analysis of the story but this is a
report on the knowledge that's been
extracted from the from the from the
sentences and put into a the kind of
knowledge framework that I showed you
when I talked about what we extract from
sentences now you can't see that of
course I'll blow it up a little bit
there's one of the elements that has
been extracted from this story with the
elements that have been extracted from
the story we fill in the gaps with
background knowledge once again that is
of course invisible so let me blow a
little of that up yeah Duncan's dead you
know that because he got killed you know
that Macbeth harmed Macduff not just
Duncan but that's because Macduff is a
friend of Dawkins and if if you kill
somebody's friend they're not real happy
about it so we have both stuff that's
explicit in the in the story and stuff
that's not it's all connected together
by relations that explain and predict
and once we have that in place then we
can begin to ask if there are patterns
in the explanation and prediction
connections that would answer the kind
of questions that we might have been
asked back and our good old humanities
classes so we might ask for example is
there a success in this story and a
pattern will be found blown up it looks
like this yes there's a success because
Macbeth wanted to be king
he murdered Duncan
as a means to achieve that end Duncan
died because Macbeth is his successor he
becomes king and so we come back again
to the left side and we see that Macbeth
is deliriously happy as a consequence of
that but then we can see if there's a
mistake and a mistake pattern is found
to Macbeth murdered Duncan that leads to
Macbeth harming Macduff that leads to
Macduff killing Macbeth and so Macduff
Macbeth is not so happy in the end after
all one of those connections is only
used in explanation it's the one that
says if you dislike somebody perhaps
you'll kill them fortunately this
doesn't have the strength of a
prediction but it's it's there only
because if there's no other kind of
explanation available in the story
that's the explanation that's presumed
so we can see other sorts of stuff in
here too there's there's our Pyrrhic
victory it's a combination of a success
and a mistake there's a revenge and what
we have in the end is a claim that we
are the stories that we've been told
some of them when we experience directly
but many of them are surrogate
experiences that are taught to us in
school through the subjects we take to
talk to us our classrooms and our they
talk to us through religion they're
taught to us through fairy tales and
sometimes they're taught to us through
propaganda because that occurs when
someone directs us to a story that has
the answer that they want now as you
look at examples like that you might say
well that's not my exactly my concept of
what a Pyrrhic victory is but that's
okay if you shake hands with a person on
the right shake hands with the person on
the left as the MIT saying goes they
will think differently about what a
Pyrrhic victory is - it's a remarkable
how we humans tend to assume that when
we have a good thought everyone else
will have the same good thought and
we'll think the same way symmetrically
we humans often suppose that when we
have a defect
it's a word is exclusively many years
ago when I was in third grade there was
a dark conversation between my teacher
and my mother because I was having
trouble learning the multiplication
tables I've never learned the
multiplication tables it's a secret I
kept till well into my faculty career
but then I discovered that my colleague
an extraordinarily intelligent friend
Gerry Sussman can't remember the
multiplication tables either we both
cheated their way around it by
remembering all of the squares I would
work off the squares so if you ask
either of us what seven times eight is
we would say well let's see seven times
seven is forty-nine so it must be seven
more than that 56 right good so you give
you one other example many people many
very bright people including my wife
have a slight pause between asking them
which direction left is and they're
identifying which way it actually is I
myself do not have that perception if
you say left I feel like I know
immediately that it's over that way so
my wife has a like many people a
noticeable delay between saying left and
identifying which way left is I'll never
forget one day I was we were driving
along and she was navigating and she
said turn left so I turned left and she
said what did you do that for
and I said I thought you said to turn
left and she sheepishly looked down and
discovered their arms were crossed
so you might ask me well what is it all
good for well of course I think it's
good for filling in part of the puzzle
of what it is that makes us humans
intelligent the story part especially
what would you do with it with it with
it with story understanding if you had
systems and understood stories what if
you insisted on a practical application
if you were to hold me in a corner at
knifepoint and ask for an example I
would cite an example that I learned
about from military historian some years
ago he was commenting on how difficult
it is to see what's going on in the fog
of war he said consider the Tet
Offensive US intelligence could see that
the Vietcong were mobilizing for an
attack US intelligence concluded that if
the Vietcong attacked they would lose US
intelligence concluded that if concluded
that the Vietcong knew that if they
attack they would lose therefore the
Vietcong won't attack and at that point
they promptly attacked five years later
the aam Kippur War Israeli intelligence
could see that the Egyptians were
mobilizing Israeli intelligence
concluded that if the Egyptians attacked
the Egyptians would lose Israeli
intelligence concluded that the
Egyptians knew that Israeli intelligence
concluded that they therefore would not
attack whereupon of course they promptly
attacked in both cases what the The
Forgotten element was that there was a
political rather than a military motive
for the attack but given you had one
why couldn't you see the other in terms
of the one why couldn't you read the the
president the history onto the new
situation and
and and and understand that from a Tudor
perspective taught by history I was
telling this story to John Reed just a
few days ago and he said that the recent
financial meltdown is a better example
that there were ample precedents that
should have informed us that what was
coming was coming just as the Israelis
should have known that the Egyptians
would attack so it's possible that we
can use this kind of idea if we focus on
applications in important ways and not
just on and using using precedents and
history and stories to understand new
situations but using it to understand
cultures I'm just saying how will play
in Peoria is a phrase I often hear I
happen to be from East Peoria so I could
never figure out why this was such a
hard problem but on the other hand I
would be completely at sea if you ask me
how something would play in Baghdad
because I've grown up in a European
culture so I've been tutored with the
judeo-christian Bible
I've been tutored with Homeric myths
I've been tutored by the national heroes
and I've been tutored by modern cinema
and entertainment which is probably not
much more than a translation of the
Homeric myths but these folks over here
would have a different set of stories on
which they would base their
interpretation of events and if we're to
understand other cultures we're going to
have to understand how stories define a
culture is it ten stories that matter or
a hundred or a thousand we don't know
but what we'd like to have in the future
is a system that would be as
indispensable to a political or
intelligence and that analysts as a
spreadsheet is to a financial analysts
something that would allow you to turn
the dials and say well this isn't going
to play very well in Baghdad
so how do we think we think with our
hands and our eyes I think with our
mouths we think with our imagination and
we think with our cultures stories and
thinking about the creation of
intelligent programs from this
perspective is a radical departure from
what we've done in the past 50 years as
we've tried to understand and build a
computational theory of intelligence for
the first 25 or 30 20 or 30 years we
were almost entirely symbolic on the way
we thought about things we thought if we
could only make a program that could do
symbolic integration would be on the way
if we could only make a program that can
understand a children's story we would
be almost there
well we figured out how to make programs
do calculus by 1960 and a great deal of
progress was made on understanding
children's stories but computers
remained as dumb as stones so for the
next 20 or 30 years we built robots
perceptual apparatus things that move no
language though so it's almost that we
forgot that the distinguishing
characteristic of human intelligence is
that linguistic veneer it stands above
our perceptual apparatus so we have
today today as we sit at that roundtable
is a growing understanding that we
humans are intelligent not because we
have a language system and not because
we have a perceptual system because we
have a language system that interacts
with a perceptual system and to use a
metaphor I could only use at MIT when
our when our language apparatus s our
visual apparatus to answer a question
it's like a Fourier transform it's
putting the question into another space
when the answer can be calculated or
more readily so without that ability to
communicate with a vision system without
that ability to imagine we would have
systems that could answer questions do
calculus but never be as anything like
never have anything like the
intelligence of a person
so this brings us to the question of why
computers make us stupid and one answer
that is that they've made it unnecessary
to take notes it's all there after all
and you can look it up everything that
happens with classrooms online any
question you might want to answer is
over there somewhere
on the web and it's not that taking
notes has any value in recording
information it has value only in that it
forces the engagement of our language
apparatus and our visual apparatus and
even our hands so it's that forced
engagement that is so valuable in in
taking notes and when you don't take
notes that engagement is not forced the
mind wanders it's like watching a movie
and thinking about something else
there's another side of this of course
and that's the instructional side the
other reason the computers make us
stupid is because we on the teaching
side to confuse the presentation of
information with the delivery of
information I'm sure you've all seen
slides that are just so packed with
words it would take you 20 minutes to
read one I was one of my students was
critiquing one of her fellow students
presentation toward the end of class
this past semester and she said well
interesting talk I've taught them always
to say that first
but you know your slides had so many
words and you talked so fast you jammed
my language processor it's like that
spell key experiment where you reduce
the professor to the rat when you cram
so much information into the language
channel there's nothing left to
understand the content of what you're
trying to convey so this is the second
of the big reasons why we computer
scientists have owe you an all an
apology it's all our fault
we made it possible to cram a lot of
information on a slide and if that's not
enough you just use a smaller font and
get even more on there so being more
optimistic what do we do if we want to
be smarter well now you know the answer
you take notes because that forces the
engagement of your linguistic and motor
and visual apparatus and you can look at
the picture after you've drawn it so you
draw pictures to your talking imagine
and if there's no one around to talk to
you can talk to yourself I do advise
some caution in this dimension however
because people who don't understand
exactly what you're doing may reach the
an incorrect conclusion neighbor of mine
for time was a prominent Boston area
psychiatrist who met whom I met once at
a at a community party and not knowing
he was a psychiatrist at the time I
attempted to strike up a conversation I
said what do you do and he said I'm a
psychiatrist silence
so I groping for something to say asked
him what kind of patience he had and he
said I only take patients that other
psychiatrists have given up on Oh I said
where do they come from
mostly MIT and Harvard
and of course he went on to explain that
there's a narrow line between or perhaps
an overlap between seeing the world in a
creative way seeing what ought to be
there but isn't and seeing things in the
world that aren't actually there
talking to Eleanor Roosevelt and
believing that she's there would be an
example of that sort of thing I suppose
so finally tell stories two of my
undergraduate students conducted an
experiment in the past month in which
100 of their friends were divided into
two groups 50 were told to read some
information about computer networks
another 50 were instructed to do the
same thing but then explain it to the
experimenter they were tested a week
later guess who did better sniffs and
it's very significant statistical level
the ones who had explained it who had
told the story right after reading it
did substantially better than those who
just read it passively so this is the
final slide a one of the show today and
I'd like to conclude just by answering
one of the questions that I'm sure is
very much on your mind you're probably
saying to yourself well I do feel a lot
smarter now having seen this
presentation and in consequence of that
it's a possible that downstream I might
make a better business decision or
perhaps invent something in consequence
of using one of these techniques and
heuristics what if I should wake up in a
in the middle of the night agonizing
over how I can express my appreciation
well remember this is the age of the web
and websites are standing by
[Applause]
here's where we find out whether in fact
we did get smarter and of course as
usual we're running quite late on time
so I'm gonna try to confine this to a
couple there there were several
questions dealing with with abstracts
and abstractions now we're going to read
these and and and whether you could get
computers to handle these kinds of
things can computers understand giving
and receiving abstractions such as Paul
gave Cindy the flu would the computer
think that Paul touched Cindy in a
related question a little bit more
direct do you think it's possible to
engineer an artificial consciousness may
or may not be the same but you'll be
able to deal with that well I find
myself thinking of techniques that we
learned in freshman humanities classes I
want to exactly answer that question
I'll answer another question I hope for
partial credit
I and of course another technique that
politicians use when you ask questions
with multiple parts also I answer one
part leave the other one alone yeah but
when you when we use words like give and
take of course there's a context
surrounding them and one of our one of
the challenges in understanding language
making computers understand languages is
the challenge of understanding how to
confine the the scope of a word use to
to those situations to in which it
actually applies and it's a long
technical discussion a one-hour lecture
and my artificial intelligence course to
discuss mechanisms that we are now
inventing that restrict the application
of an interpretation to exactly the
right part of the world to which it
would apply so for example if we say
what's furry and we say well dogs are
furry and rugs are furry cars are not
furry we now built and discovered define
and refine mechanisms that that shrink
our knowledge of furriness around
exactly the kinds of concepts that
should be considered furry without
letting it leak off and and and and
cause us to misinterpret something else
so bringing that back to the question
about give and take certainly we know
that most gives involve the movement of
a physical object from one person to
another but if you give someone a cold I
still got it it's a different kind of
give it's a different interpretation of
the word it's syntactically the same but
from the point of view of the meaning
that it stimulates and the meaning
interpretation that it stimulates the
other person it's quite different and we
believe we can make that happen there
was another question about abstractions
and and you know abstractions are
something that we worry about all the
time because that's that's that kind of
abstraction is is the great
differentiator of human intelligence so
it's very much on our agenda
the last question then we really must
break there was quite a bit of interest
in your experiments with with rats and
MIT professors and if I can find this
while you're looking for it I'll tell
you about an experiment with chimpanzees
that I've been much taken with and
involves a mean human being that can be
me and a monkey chimpanzee that can be
you and here's how the experiment goes
if I'm if I put the banana here you as
the chimpanzee will not approach it
unless I put a blindfold on my eyes then
you'll come and steal the banana so I
mentioned this only because Rebecca was
talking a great deal about those parts
of our brain apparatus that are devoted
to understanding what the other what the
other agent is thinking it seems that
that's even that that a version of that
is even present in the chimpanzee well
the question was
I was hoping I was hoping we were right
out inside it's actually pretty direct
it's not too confusing there won't be a
linguistic problem here I think if you
if you paint one wall with an odor does
the rat function as well as the MIT
professor yeah obviously an odor instead
of a color you know as far as I know
it's it's not known there are many
fascinating questions that are
experiments that can be suggested many
of which are still underway there's a
question of whether this works with
chimpanzees or not there's the question
of whether it works with humans who
don't appear to have a notion of left
and right but rather made judgments
about direction on an absolute north
south east but many of these things are
very controversial and have yet to have
not produced any any any information
that we can make yourself okay thank you
so much
you